in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to an episode of the
genius brain podcast if you guys haven't
heard of this podcast before you are a
[ __ ] loser so so we have a very very
special guest today and this guess I
gotta tell you it's I have always wanted
to interview somebody who is a dating
expert so what a lot of people don't
know on this podcast and I've given
dating advice but my dating advice is
very [ __ ] loose cuz I really don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
it won't with any topics but like
they'll ask specifically on this podcast
I think it's because when they look at
my prototype right and they go oh this
guy has had girlfriends before they go
I'm a loser just like him how the [ __ ]
did he do it well first of all that's
offensive but second of all you just go
out there and you see what happens right
and that's the only advice that I could
really give because I've never I never
really thought twice about it
right I think that um I think just cuz
I'm a funny dude
so I always use comedy to go ahead and
talk to women but not everybody has that
skill so you I don't even know if people
like this though do you like the term
pickup artists I don't like the term
pickup artists at all and I don't have
any pickup artist friends that are
pickup artists coaches I think they're
slimy and not real and pretentious yeah
so this is Cosmo by the way it's Cosmo
Cosmo side your real name so my real
name is Albert Orlando manrique that's
[ __ ] tight
I don't get you [ __ ] right there dude
that's already done my name is David so
died it doesn't do anything good The
Adventures of David Stone so my real
name is alvaro Orlando man Rica and my I
guess breakdancing dating coach name is
Cosmo also you b-boy as well yeah what
in the [ __ ] didn't you do dude I have a
crazy story man look ok so first of all
before he even came here I found out
that he puts a Golden Gloves amateur
boxer if you guys don't know what a
[ __ ] Golden Gloves amateur boxers
that's like upper echelon and when it
comes to amateur boxing that's [ __ ]
insane how did you okay how did you get
into malls listen we'll go to the b-boys
[ __ ] how did you get into boxing I got
into boxing by getting my ass beat a lot
of times in Miami and I'm like I need to
learn how to protect myself and it was a
sense of you know you know to be honest
I'm just
tell you when I when I was small I had
on like a lot of anxiety had a really
bad relation I'm just gonna like getting
right into the or sure I had a bad
relationship with my mom and I was like
uh perfect kind of like you could see me
at 45 being a [ __ ] and um why that
came from is cuz I'm always always
worried about the future you understand
it was like oh my mom is it like she
would get into fights with guys oh [ __ ]
I came from a really rough childhood and
you one thing that kept me present was
boxing it kept me in a moment it made me
feel like I don't think about the past
or the future and it just was like the
biggest release of like endorphins
mm-hmm at peace did I cotta me right
like getting punched in the face and
feeling like thankful yeah and that's
why I got into it and a lot of fighters
get into it because they have that
something to get out that like they've
been mistreated or they have that rage
I've never met a really rich person with
no childhood issues get into boxing and
excel I've never met one person yeah so
is this for you go into to get out a lot
of your demons you know like cuz I just
started doing kickboxing maybe two and a
half years ago right and then when we
started switching over to boxing first
of all like boxing is such a a difficult
physical science right just I think um
there's so many parts to it that I
didn't realize like specifically anybody
could just start swinging their [ __ ]
arms right but when you meet when you
meet up with somebody who's a technician
they're precise with their punches it's
a completely different story they could
see every single move that you're about
to do and I think when I first started
boxing and that happened to me I got
scared I was like I can't that was the
first time I felt like no matter what I
throw this person's gonna hit me in the
face yeah yeah it is a very frightening
[ __ ] feeling it's like oh this
there's a there's a complete difference
to boxing and then street fighting yeah
street fighting you'll see what happens
whoever gets cracked first is probably
the person that's gonna lose but when
you box somebody and you look at their
face and they have no emotions it's like
this guy's gonna kill me the thing
that's very I absolutely agree with
everything you said street fighting if
you think about it you puff up your
chest you're like longest three fight
like 15 seconds let's think about that
one
- that's a long time in boxing you have
a long time in that ring and you cannot
quit yeah so you can't lie about
anything in boxing and a lot of times if
you feel like you're like a fraud in
some areas of your life boxing will just
nail you right there
yeah like no dude this is what you're
about did you did you want to make
boxing into a career originally um I did
but I in my heart I knew I was not never
gonna be top 300 fighters in the world
oh really
I knew it in my heart and so when I
discovered acting and being in front of
the camera I without sounding cocky or
anything in my heart I do feel like I'm
I have potential to be one of like top I
up there I think that's the that's a the
hard part for a lot of people they feel
like they have so many options but when
you kind of hone in and you feel like
something is right for you that's what
you really have to tackle because I
think a lot of like young people
nowadays they go well I can do whatever
I want
it's very true but you have to take the
time to kind of figure out what you're
gonna be great at right and I think
sometimes we can fool ourselves into
believing the things that we want is the
thing that's gonna cause us to be really
great cuz like for me I think I
originally wanted to be a musician right
which I still do music on the side but
then for me I tackle doing comedy
instead because I felt like this was
really my calling and I had to drop that
for a second not to say that you can't
pursue that at another time but it's
kind of where does your talents in your
heart lie and that's the hard part where
you have to make that choice it's like I
enjoy this but there's something else
that's going to be my calling and so you
went from that to acting and then from
acting you went on the show was at the
pickup artists yeah so what was that it
was a show on vh1 yes so let me rewind
just a little bit yeah yeah so I was
born and raised in Miami and then yeah I
got into fighting boxing and then at 18
I started working for a Spanish network
called Univision okay
and I work for like the Spanish Oprah
like Don Francisco right okay so when I
was younger I thought I was the thug so
I had all these dreadlocks and all that
but when people would talk to me I was
really friendly I'm always about
positive vibes emoting like just being
your true self so the don't a Cisco
would call me like the gay thug
I was a walking contradiction bro you
look like you're tough then I talked to
you and he's like you're soft he's like
you're you hug people and people
compliments like thugs you supposed to
be like man [ __ ] you I don't like you
bruh yeah so one day he froze in front
of national live TV and he did that a
lot he like he liked to mess with people
so I was behind the camera and he's like
flirty one benbeckie on national TV and
he got me in front of the camera and
he's like I want you to do a skit I'm
gonna put a wig on you and you were
going on a blind date and you have to
try to seduce me or whatever cuz you try
to make people feel uncomfortable I've
never in my life been in front of a
camera ever and as soon as I got there
bro it was the weirdest feeling I felt
like I did in boxing but 10 times more
comfortable huh with a high intensity of
like panic and knowing that millions of
people are watching me I shined I just
was in my element I came in out of
nowhere and I'm like oh yeah this go
better and I got into character I'm like
what am i doing and it felt like my
higher self like something took over and
was like bro this is where you need it
what you need to do for the rest of your
life and then I got done and he looked
at me in a commercial break the whole
audience got up they started applauding
should I'm getting killed right now and
and in that moment I'm like I'm gonna
dedicate my entire life to this till I'm
99 years old like my entire life I'm
gonna dedicate to this I moved to New
York one week later I sold my car my
family thought I was going nuts my
friends were like bro you okay
I left cuz for the first time in my life
I'm like this is what I need to do and a
week later I moved to New York by myself
with $2,000 in my bank account
on the third day in New York I got
hustled for a thousand seven hundred so
you do the math what in the fog welcome
to New York bro I was like what how do
they hustle you for 1,700 though as an
actor you don't need to pay to get an
agent they only make money off of you
but I just got there and I was on 42nd
Street walking I'm like I'm going to be
an actor this is going to be my corner
and one guy smelled like oh my god this
guy's like you know cattle and he came
up to me he's like you have a look he's
like you have this look so he's like
give me $1,700 and I'll be your agent
and I'll take headshots and I'll take
you out
auditions I'm not lying dude a week
later I went to the to the place like
this you know this yeah this room nobody
was there they were gone
they took maybe like 3040 actor so it
I'm bad at math like 50 grand forty five
grand
holy [ __ ] that's a good an episode of
Friends yeah that's [ __ ] cloudy Joey
that's [ __ ] crazy I'm an so from okay
so you got stripped of 1,700 bucks you
had $300 to your name what was your next
move after that besides crying I'm I was
crying for a long time I moved in with
my cousin in his little room in Spanish
Harlem where I would take my little boom
box in my red bandana and go breakdance
at the park
one day these gangsters all Bloods I
should have noticed didn't notice they
stopped me and they're like where are
you from and I'm like I'm from Miami
they're like very calmly they said it
like this we're gonna kill you we're
gonna kill you if you don't take that
bandana off and the reason why all in
Spanish and the reason why we're not
doing it right now
it's because you look so out of place
right now oh sure now I'm like and all
we're talking in Spanish I don't leap it
okay look up I saw this and that and
then he's like the red bandana take that
[ __ ] off right now bro and as he's
talking I've never seen as he takes a
razor blade out of his mouth and I take
my red bandana off and I have a little
boom box set it off I wanna live now and
all the guys behind him you see him like
kind of running up and he's like so
you're Miami I'm like yeah I'm CUBAN
Colombian he's like I'm gonna believe
you bro
he's like don't ever wear red in his
neighborhood I in 116 and third Avenue
this was 2000 and holy [ __ ] brother I
was like yes sir
and then he's like yeah what are you
doin like I breakdance and I move for
acting he's like well we all go smoke
weed at that park where do you break
down so I'm like at the park not lying
dude they would go by the bench all
smoke and do other drugs and they would
just watch me break dance on the
linoleum clappy and be like yeah that
there tamaco so like everywhere like God
was telling me like yo you're getting
away with you're being an entertainer
like that is saving your life right now
so I live the Spanish Harlem for a while
every time I saw the gangsters they love
me they're like he's an artist
like a dancer goofy guy yeah and then I
got cast on his national TV show called
the roof where I would interview people
and walk up to them in the street and be
like hey and say stupid [ __ ] yeah at
this point I hid it from my family my
friends that had trouble talking to
women and in Miami I lied to everyone
I said Braun getting so much [ __ ] I
have so many prom dates that I'm not
gonna go to my high school prom because
I have someone in Boca Raton or West
Palm Beach that I'm going I lied to
everyone I had no prom date because for
my whole life I could never walk up to a
girl and talk to them but I was like you
I was very funny I was quick but that
only got me so far yeah yeah yeah it
because then there would they would get
D like endorphins they would laugh and
then it would go have sex with the Alpha
exactly how will I get him revved up and
then they're like I'm out you got to
close the deal yeah yeah so I you know
this whole time in New York I'm
struggling I'm struggling with that I'm
booking a lot of indie films eating tuna
just a Roth dude just like really rough
they're like typical Hollywood II story
right like really rough and I would
break dance in a subway for like $80 a
day dude it was just tough and then um I
call my cousin one day in in Florida and
I'm like yo I'm moving out to LA next
week you want to come with me cuz I need
you cuz I heard in LA everybody does
cocaine and they're crazy and they're
all thinking I'm gonna go nuts and he
moved out with me man oh [ __ ]
and within very quickly getting to LA I
get cast on a huge reality show and that
was and that was the pickup artist what
was the objective of that show to learn
how to talk to women also wait so you or
somebody that was being taught how to
talk to my 110 percent bro Oh what the
[ __ ] I've never in my life nice promise
you have walked up to a girl before that
show and said hey how you doing i'm
alvaro nothing I've gotten laid before
when I was young only because the girl
did all the work yeah yeah she's like
due to your cue what are you doing I'm
like man
yeah literally I I couldn't hide it
anymore because it was affecting other
areas of my life and so I was one of the
eight losers and a very tall Canadian
guy called mystery the world's greatest
pickup artist taught eight losers how to
talk to women holy [ __ ] I thought it was
the other you were the pickup artists on
the show I was absolutely not degraded
at all and if you guys haven't seen a
pickup artist and I'm gonna make you
watch it bro it is it'll make you laugh
and then in like Episode three or
episode 4 it it took everybody by storm
and they're like tearjerker moments in
their word America is watching they're
like oh [ __ ] this is real this is really
bad hmm people going through depression
social anxiety like this is really bad
yeah yeah I'm getting a lot of kills
today and so it's the very proud of it
but at the time I was not why not
because I'm an artist I we're talking
about I'm an artist I want to do this
movie movie and I wanted and I want to
dig deep and just like a reality show
and like at the time like in Kim
Kardashian was blowing up yeah you know
like I was like I don't want to be these
[ __ ] mhm and I resisted it but
um
yeah man III don't know why I mean I I
um you know the my mindset changed when
I got my first suicide letter and
somebody said um hey you don't know me I
saw your show on from Europe and
watching your show I just want to let
you know I got over a bad breakup and
was thinking of killing myself well I
saw you in the show you get my god here
we go again chills I mean I got I got um
motivated to live life and III want to
live now and I think I'm worthy when I
got that I was like oh talking to myself
you're a selfish prick you're only
thinking about yourself like oh I'm an
artist is like no how could I help
people and empower people and when I
started to have that outlook everything
in my life changed this podcast is
brought to you by purple my friends if
you've never placed your body on a
purple batteries you have no idea what
you are missing out on my whole life I
slept on some of the crappiest mat
mrs. mattress seized I don't know how to
PluralEyes that my whole life and I'm
and I kid you not like sleeping on a
purple mattress has really changed my
perspective on sleep I didn't realize
how important it was to have a great
mattress I didn't realize how much time
I did spend in my life trying to sleep
well guess what when it comes to comfort
purple mattress has got your back let me
just name a couple of reasons why it's
awesome it has guaranteed comfort
there's no hassle shipping every purple
mattress ships free and is delivered
right to your door if you're not
completely satisfied the purple team
will help you pick up your mattress at
no cost risk free trial per per is
purple purple is so confident in what
they do every mattress comes with a
hundred night risk-free trial if you
guys are sleeping on something
uncomfortable and you think that it's
okay you're absolutely wrong
you can mess up your back from that mess
up your sleep and when you sleep better
you think better you feel better and
it's great for your immunity did you
know that when you get a good solid
whatever 7 to 8 hours of sleep it helps
your immune system yes it does I didn't
know that my doctor told me that so
check it out experience the next
evolution of sleep go to purple comm
slash GB and use promo code GB for a
limited time you'll get a hundred and
fifty dollars off any purple matches
order of 1,500 or more that's purple
comm slash GB promo code GB for a
hundred and fifty dollars off any
mattress order of 1,500 or more terms
apply so for you as I mean if not the
the coinage or the term pick up artists
and what is something that we should I
like social empowerment okay so for you
when you're like socially empowering
people right I mean I I'm always trying
to figure out when when guys always ask
another guy right like how do you talk
to women how do you do it like why why
is that so important to men to want to
always have to have this ability to talk
to women like it wasn't really a stress
in my life I think when I was younger
when I was like maybe 13 or 14 I was
trying to figure out how to do it but
after a while I kind of just like I [ __ ]
it and see what happens right so in your
opinion then with these people who you
know for example that guy who emailed
you what's like that male importance to
have to constantly want to to grab a
girl's attention and make them like them
like what's that obsession about
I'm assuming you're in a relationship
right now yes okay let's say I'm sorry
I'm just gonna go in to you real quick
so let's say that you got a breakup
right now hopefully it never happens and
because you're human you're gonna get
heartbroken you're gonna get sad so now
let's put you in a headspace of like two
months going in this breakup where do
you think your head's at right now two
months into the breakup probably still
really depressed so like after three
four five months getting after the
depression like where do you think you
would be if we can get kind of like take
a ballpark here and no these are kind of
deviations I know they're in the back at
you well I think maybe from me I think
just like most people I probably deflect
into work right so instead of having to
deal with my emotions I would deflect it
into something else right you just
nailed it you know because most men they
have you ever heard of a beautiful girl
going I can't wait to make $200,000 a
year and get a Ferrari so I can [ __ ] a
guy so I can get a guy of my dreams
never how many times do you see guys
going I'm gonna be a CEO and I'm gonna
make a lot of money so I can buy a Lambo
and get a beautiful girl you see four
guys were hardwired that way right to
have a beautiful girl in our life
whether it's physical or emotionally
somebody that can make you laugh they
make you feel live but what happens is
when you run against that you nailed it
people get into work a lot they get
obsessed with work because they're like
well I just got to work I'm too busy I
can't go out and they hide from the fact
that no dude you can do work and you can
go out and get the girl of your dream or
the girls of your dream and go out and
be social but you're you nailed it like
you would get into your work a lot yeah
that's what a lot of people do smash cut
to three years later they got a breakup
three years into work and now they're
like okay I'm going to Vegas for my
friend's bachelor party
holy [ __ ] I have a problem talking to
women like they had let away any moment
of join here oh my god I've been numbing
myself this whole time so that's what
happens a lot in my cases they they they
go I'm good I'm good I'm good till
they're not and then they go okay I need
help yeah I could kind of see that
because if you if you've
I guess in my case if that happened and
I just deflected I went towards work for
maybe two or three years and there's
like a it's time to date again okay what
the [ __ ] you nailed it because I was in
a relationship for like I don't know
wasn't when I was six years right it's
six years and everything was fine I
didn't have to go ahead and practice
these skills and then hiatus three years
and then now it's like hey Dave again I
might be like okay what the [ __ ] do I do
now
were you born with talking to having the
ability to talk to him and you say that
you think that you were born with it cuz
I wasn't at all no I mean I I think just
like you I had I still do have major
anxiety so I take CBD [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time I think like the the
biggest difference that I've seen from
other guys who are very similar to me I
also had this other this other problem
of like I don't say problem by my
motivating factor is that if I if I can
pinpoint and recognize something that I
feel is a flaw in myself that I can
change I want to beat that [ __ ] out of
me so you know when I had that anxiety
thing you know I was like you you this
is a you problem
you can fix this nobody's stopping you
it's you and so when I I just kept doing
it that's how going to stand up like
stand up to me used to people understand
what I used to do stand up I should I
could still remember what it felt like
it felt like there was an anvil and my
[ __ ] stomach before I went onstage
and it used to hurt me like physically
hurt me to get on stage and tell these
jokes but then you know that that part
of my head that was like shut the [ __ ]
up just go and [ __ ] do it and so I
would just go up there and if I bomb I
bomb I didn't care and I think at the
end of it when I realizes you're still
alive like you're not dead
what would have happened if you didn't
go up there like you have everything the
game but nothing to lose and so that
that kind of thing is the the one I
think the biggest difference that I have
compared to some of the other people
were asking me this advice you know you
know it's funny I have UFC fighters that
are my clients oh really and I look at
them and I'm like bro you're getting in
a ring fighting the best fighters in the
world and you're telling me you can't
walk up those four girls right now
you're like nope really promise you
Hollywood promoters karate teachers Navy
SEALs and are a general from like an
army like the craziest people that do
the like things that I could never
you go walk up to those four girls with
the two guys okay no no no right now
hold on they can't they cannot what what
is that ego humiliation I'd rather get
my ass beat a UFC fighters thinking than
to walk up to four girls and them go
you're such a loser get out of my face
and all the people behind them laughing
at him that is their worst nightmare
that humiliation is like people's worst
fear by far that I've seen it's really
rare that you can walk you can like talk
to someone that are so comfortable
walking into humiliation and rejection
every day and when you usually meet that
person you don't want them out of your
life because they're operating off of
such a high frequency yeah like oh let's
go out right now to Olive Garden I'll go
talk to three girls in front of you but
Cosmo you're gonna get rejected man so
what like that's such a big time freedom
at least for me yeah like being able to
walk up to anyone anywhere it gave me so
much freedom and a lot of people don't
have that that's so interesting cuz I
you know I had a friend of mine who was
on this podcast he does a podcast for me
every now and then and he has that bat
issue right there
it's before he even starts he sees the
rejection and the rejection it paralyzes
him like he he just can't like I would
talk to him about and on the podcast we
talked about like a rejection that he
had before which wasn't even really a
rejection but when he tells the story he
tells it like it happened yesterday and
happened when he was 14 you know so I'm
like I know I'm asking was like when did
this happen and I he's like when I was
like 14 or 15 I'm like bro you're like
26 you know that's the trauma right like
I know we're joking around but it's like
a trauma that's like a trigger for him
if he's 14 years old how z30 there's
like 26 or something that's the trauma
yeah that's over ten years ago he's
talking about it that that's traumatic
yeah and like the one and I'm [ __ ] I
even think about that yeah but we don't
think of it because we look at romantic
comedies or we look at YouTube skits and
we're like oh look at the guy talking a
girl hey how you doin and so we we cover
it with comedy and but when we take away
the comedy dude it's dark
yeah these are look I'm getting chills
all over the place I don't know if you
remember a Leon gun whatever his name
was he killed like eight girls ran him
over in UCLA I think was like eight
years ago Ellie on something we can
Google or whatever he hated pickup
artist because all he wanted to do is
ask a girl out and he couldn't so he
killed people instead of [ __ ] calling
me and being like yo I have problems
talking to women can you help me I swear
on everything I could have changed a
kid's life but he was so anger and rage
the women are [ __ ] and this and that
he killed people and then killed himself
these are huge things that we don't talk
about in America in high school and
middle school [ __ ] all these electives
we need to have social dynamic classes
yes where oh my god I like a teacher
we'll go okay we're gonna get a guy to
come up I know there's a girl's here how
does he walk up to girls how does he ask
you for dance and really talk about it
but because America's so cool we don't
want to talk about that man not is
saying [ __ ] we don't need to talk about
that [ __ ] you know it's a big problem
man I really do agree with that stuff
too because I think a lot of the stuff
that you know younger people deal with
but I dealt with when I was younger it's
it's that social dynamic part that
people don't really focus on so what
sometimes when I go on these college
shows and these kids know it too and I
and I just try to have a regular
conversation with them I'm like you are
socially awkward like nobody taught you
how to converse with the person or even
socially interact with somebody that you
don't know and I think just seeing that
and that kind of obviously that will
translate into them trying to work with
the plot whether it's a female or male
right and I think that part right there
is has always been a weird issue for me
I don't know if it's because we do so
many things online now that they don't
have to be real because I'll see some of
these kids right and I'll see how they
write to me on Instagram or when they DM
me right I'm like this was not the
person that I met in person if you could
speak like how you speak to me here in
real life you would probably get rid of
that anxiety that you have but it's so
interesting III wonder if it's because
people can hide behind a screen and you
know their Instagram or whatever that
they don't have to practice these things
so when it actually comes to them
meeting somebody
um they kind of fell it like for example
I have a friend right now who's she's
doing online dating right she's coaching
no she's doing online dating she's I
don't know which app she's on but she
was just telling me about the date that
she had with this guy and the moment
that she I she came back a little
irritated I was like well what happened
on the date right and she was bored
we're talking and then he just kept
grilling me with questions over and over
and over and over and over and I was
like oh I could kind of see what he was
trying to do I was like well what was he
trying to do I was like he probably read
something online that says don't make
the conversations about you making about
her he just kept asking you questions
over and over and over I was like he's a
little you know socially awkward and
that's really what it is
what was her feedback like what would
she have wanted friend to do I think she
was she said that she wanted was just a
casual conversation and I think what he
was trying to do was he kind of probably
had like ticked off these boxes of
conversations that would lead into
something else and so instead of
listening to what she was saying he just
had the questions that he wanted to ask
and so like for that I was telling her
like well he's just he's awkward you
know it's not because he's a bad guy
like for example on the first date he
goes like what do you think about the
BLM stuff it's like bro that's a very
first date conversation kind of bad for
the guy you know cuz he's trying I know
what he's trying to do it's like he's
trying to make her feel comfortable by
asking her questions versus him just
talking about himself but he didn't
allow a segue to happen but straight to
BLM it's like you know that's that's a
deep conversation on a first date right
yeah absolutely and when somebody tells
me it's a guys trying I'm so empathic
towards all these guys are struggling
but he's not really trying because I've
used trying just like if you me wanted
to lose 15 pounds we would just go to
the gym or we would get a coach that's
the problem that I'm talking about like
they wanted just like shortcut to
something they eat everyone should go
out and get a coach my dating coach or
go you know public speaking and try that
out like there's no shortcut to being
calibrated or socially savvy there's no
shortcut like you have to learn the art
form the craft if you don't know it I
was I wasn't born with it
I wasn't born with it so I had to learn
it and unfortunately there
is very little women and you see your
your friend is not even in his category
because she couldn't describe it she's
like I just wanted a casual conversation
yeah what the [ __ ] does that mean you
see what I mean like yeah every little
girl's can actually go look Cosmo
tell your friend that when he said and
they break it down but that's not the
girl's job girls speak emotionally and
intuitive guys are logical and rational
so the girls like I wasn't feeling him
he had bad vibes but I'm like but why oh
yeah like what does that mean yeah
therefore they're never gonna learn from
the girl because you're gonna keep
making the same mistake because the girl
can't give you feedback mmm she's just
gonna say you make me feel weird dude or
you're too intense or I was trying to
have a casual conversation I hate it
when my home girls tell my clients just
be confident and be yourself yeah that's
so very weird one we don't really need
to take cosmos bootcamp I love him but
just be confident and be yourself and
then I'm like all right let's go out
tonight they go up this happened so many
times and I'm like hey mrs. dating coach
right go help him out
okay sweetie come here yeah just be
confident right how you feel anxious I
know but don't feel like she's just be
confident okay and I want you to be
yourself but I just got a divorce and I
live in my mom's basement okay just go
approach her you see how that doesn't
work it's like sometimes you have to
actually have like things planned on
what you're gonna tell a girl so when
you freeze up you have a back-up plan
unlike what you can do and the guy that
your homegirl went out with he had a
checklist and I do believe that you
should have an agenda and to be honest I
don't know of a lot of people are gonna
push back on this on your your platform
I believe in pickup lines more than
anything and here's why yeah exactly but
I but I think I do I'm gonna tell you
exactly why so I think once you know
what you're gonna say your key points
when you're walking up to a girl like
you know that every time I talk about my
dog to start the story works and then I
have these routines it frees up the guy
to kind of like not worry about what
he's gonna say or what are
or like I'm running out of things to say
and what happens is he starts to really
focus on like the delivery the way he's
gonna make the town house gonna make her
laugh and it gets them more creative
rather than a guy if I teach them all
mindset and I'm like okay just what
we're gonna do and I also do like NLP
and hypnosis so I teach a mindset
they're good but they don't have like a
strategy in place so they kind of get
lost so usually the person that has like
the routines and stuff like that they
get ahead and they get better and
ultimately after 12 to 15 minutes
talking to a girl you can let go of that
and now you have room to really play and
make mistakes and things like that so
the pickup line is more of a segue to
get you in your comfort zone and so once
you once you do it repetitiously it just
gets better and better and you kind of
hone it down a little bit
absolutely let me ask you a question so
what do you think how would you coach a
guy we had a guy right now we're going
to a couple bars down here what would
you tell him to say to a group of three
girls like what do you think his moaning
line could be if you had a guy right now
that was like brother can you help me
like what do you think you would say to
him damn [ __ ] I don't even know you know
what I mean we don't talk about that
yeah I don't mean I don't never thought
about that yeah because it's so tough
cuz I think I was like your home world I
was like yo man just you're I know you
as a good guy
they all know you you're a good guy if
you just open up and just get out of
your head but what the [ __ ] does that
really mean that's probably some really
terrible advice that I give ya so I have
a pick-up line that works every single
time and I've actually done this at a
club or events where I've told a girl
the same line like I came back an hour
later oh the same group of girls like
hey guys and then they're like you told
us that an hour ago
dude with my techniques what I thought
we were with what I coach I stayed there
and actually those three girls that
called me out are still my friends right
now and I still hang out with so there's
no way that you can reject me unless
you're literally like I don't want to
talk to you like stop I respect that
but when they said that I plow through
and I got them to laugh and it was all
about like so let me just tell you the
best pick-up line that I think so you
walk up to the ground like everyone's
listening right now is like
my god Billy please so you walk up to a
group of girls and also to I walk up to
like when I'm working like it could be
two girls and five guys guys could be
huge alpha guys with tattoos and I'll
still walk up I'll leave with the guys
number to be like yeah man let's kick it
I'll hit a commonality with him
I like my objective is to make as many
friends as I could so I walk up and I go
hey guys real quick I just wanted to
come over and introduce myself I feel
like you have really good energy I'm
Cosmo just had to say that and I'm doing
it with my hands like that to show you
that I'm non-threatening just wanted to
come real quick and say bro you have
really good vibes like good energy
that's it and my I'm acting as if I'm
walking away that's it
so when I'm opening with that line it's
only giving value you're not getting
anything that's it so let's say the
worst case scenario like real quick just
want to come over like I was literally
with my boy David over there and it felt
like you guys had really good vibes and
we're about to dip right now I just want
to say you know whatever my name is
Cosmo and then so they go in return he
didn't compliment me on my looks he
didn't ask me what's my name
where are you from what are you doing
here automatically the last like ten
guys that came up to her you're now
unique hmm and you can walk away with
that line without getting rejected I did
it in Venice Muscle Beach and I'm like
hey real quick just went to come over
introduce myself seem like you have good
energy I'm Cosmo like thank you I'm like
yeah I get this and I go into like you
know all of my technique that I have and
it's not shady or anything my objective
is to UM you know entertain her have a
good conversation get to know her
empower her brother her husband was
walking behind me no-neck and all just
like debo most guys once the husband
came there she's like hey babe this is
Cosmo meet him most guys would have been
like oh my god dude I'm so sorry I did
you see that to me shady yeah she's like
hey babe is Cosmo and there's four
seconds of like massive uncomfort bro I
look right at him I'm like your wife's
awesome yeah and I just talked to him as
if like she was my homegirl
yeah and and then I just met her her
husband and her boyfriend yeah and um
long story short like three weeks later
they're at one of my pool parties like
it's great really cool I never try to
have sex with her right yeah I never did
anything I'm like am I gonna get in
trouble for walking up to strangers like
why I'm not touching her I'm not asking
for anything I'm just like talking to
people yeah so the minute that I stayed
there and the guy is like why is he not
walking away and why is he still talking
to me all cool he and I hit a
commonality with him I'm like I used to
box he's like used to box bro I've only
won here so once I hit the commonality
which is another good technique we were
vibing yeah like it was all good I think
that one of the important things to is
intention right I think like when guys
come off really a messages me thinking
it's like when guys come off a hyper
aggressive which I've seen a lot of guys
do that percentage rate of you opening
that door is way [ __ ] smaller and so
like I cause I have a lot of friends who
are girls right and you know my fiance
knows this too and I think one of the
things that they always told me is that
my intentions were never even if a guy
says that they want to be friends women
are very intuitive
they're very perceptive if you're trying
to [ __ ] them they could feel that you're
trying to [ __ ] them you know what I mean
and so I think like for me well my
parents aren't abusive I suppose I've
been around women a lot oh what a beauty
supply store okay so like I think I took
on a lot of like these female
characteristics and that when I was
younger but then I didn't realize well
you know and it helped me out as an
adult because like when I speak to women
I'm just talking to you
you know I mean there isn't any intent
behind it whether I find that whether I
found that girl attractive or not it was
just to talk but here's where the game
changes that let me just interrupt a
quick what are you referring to like
you're referring to the women coming
into your mom and dad's shop or are you
referring to women coming out around
your social circle cuz out what I'm
referring to it's cold approach like
literally like me you hanging out at the
beach and I'm like yo go talk to those
four girls you see how it's a little bit
for sure yeah yeah for sure there's a
huge distinction if it was the cold
approach thing it was it was still a
little nerve-racking but once I had a
couple of shots I'm like let's do it you
know the rejection part thing I got kind
of used to because of stand-up
I think stand-up kind of scarred me a
little bit it's like would you go up on
stage
nobody [ __ ] laughs at you and they
think you're a [ __ ] loser
going up to one person having them
reject
kind of just didn't feel like anything
anything to me at that point I just felt
like I didn't have too much to lose I
mean I'm not saying I wasn't stricken
with anxiety but I you know like I said
I would always had that conversation of
you're not going to die just [ __ ] do
it see what happens and I think for me
my success rate was low cuz I didn't
have like you said a specific plan when
I would go in and I would just wing it
and when I went wing it it was like
sometimes it was really great but most
of the times it wasn't because I didn't
know where we're just you know jump off
from you nail did let me go back to what
you're saying intention
it is intention but first it has to
start with verbal so if I want them to
go I'm like you have good energy bro
we're in 2020 everything is about energy
everything is about good vibes
everything is about Law of Attraction
and you can't really argue that like
think about it what's the worst thing
that a girl can tell me no I don't why'd
you why are you talking to me like
that's the worst thing they could say
but if I come up like all the guys do
hey what up what's your name Vanessa
oh cool were you from it's like why like
why are you sucking so much value for me
right so it is about two verbal but
underneath the verbal it is all about
your intention so how I coach is I'll
make them say a line and under the line
I put an active intention little her to
befriend her to intimidate her to seduce
her whatever it is to play around with
their delivery right so I make a really
good analogy with Dave Chapelle Dave
Chappelle can come up to me and say [ __ ]
your mother Cosmo now to be like because
his intention is to make you laugh huh
now a regular guy says that we're
probably gonna get into a fight but that
it's all about intention I know I'm
programmed that Dave Chappelle's
intention is to make me laugh to
entertain me so he can get away with so
much things cuz I know that he wants to
make people laugh like that's the thing
do you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
when you go with the intention my
intention would I always tell guys is
dude just make them feel better you have
no idea what they're going through in
their life just make them feel better
yeah and and if you get rejected who
cares but what I coach is if you get
rejected do never ever ever call a girl
a [ __ ] or get mad at them of course
you're the idiot that didn't come with
your A game not her survive and
replicate right so she's weeding out the
low value guys that she perceives
that won't get her head in life it's
just you know if she's like dis guy is
not gonna be anything
high-value guy in my life nothing
personal but I got to go to the bathroom
or my friend Davis yeah you know like
don't make up anything just walk away
but I hate it when guys get mad at girls
for them just rejecting them you know
what I mean like I don't teach that I
teach the guy you get rejecting all
right have a good day life's good
god bless like and just walk away yeah
what is your opinion on this cuz I uh I
have my opinion on there but I'm still
curious to you what do you what do you
think about this term like friendzone
right can I know a lot of guys use that
and I've always hated that phrase since
since ever because every time I saw a
guy that couldn't they're like oh I got
friends on us I actually they just don't
like you too
I don't know is the friendzone thing you
know yeah so what I believe in is
there's three different sections those
attraction building attraction with the
girl then there's comfort then your
seduction because of the me to movement
and everything that's going on I never
talk about seduction nor do I teach it
so I kind of cut off that comfort three
stage is an attraction opening first
impression
second one is demonstrating higher value
the girls like okay so I don't think
you're weird and you approach me cool
confident a lot of courage so tell me
why we should go out or like it now's
your turn to talk right third stage is
now she has to impress you which is a
qualification stage now the guy is like
yeah cool so what so what about you what
do you have going on for you like what
so what do you do and now the girl talks
about herself well I want to open up a
business I've seen your podcast you
inspire me I want to do a podcast too
and now you're at even levels right so
you're out of the attraction phase and
now you go into comfort three phases
Comfort trust and intimacy yeah I can
feel comfortable around someone but not
trust them so Trust is bigger than
comfort and in after trusses intimate
being intimate with someone you
Wednesday night Netflix chill like
cuddling with them like just emoting
about your insecurities things like that
I do believe that what happens in a
friend zone is that the guy will skip
over the whole attraction phase and
he'll go right into comfort ah so I do
believe that there is a
zone because she doesn't find him like
I'm just gonna be real Adams I don't
want to be real but like her [ __ ] won't
get wet she does not [ __ ] horny she's
not like oh my god like I'm gonna [ __ ]
him her she doesn't feel jealous like if
he's like I'm going out with my friend
Amanda she's like all right cool she's
not like Oh who's Amanda you know that
jealousy is a big thing if the girl
doesn't feel jealous about you there's
no attraction there whatsoever so the
guy just skipped into comfort and she
views him as somebody that she can call
with she's at 2:00 in the morning I had
sex with a guy and regretted it he'll
pick her up want to go in now need a
burger and talk about life like it is
true so they're stuck in a comfort zone
so they use so that's like a personal
responsibility thing to then right so
you placed yourself there absolutely is
their fault 100% all the way and there
is a way to get out of it oh really yeah
because I was in a friend zone with so
many girls before I went on the show I
disappeared for eight weeks doing a
reality show and it came back and I was
a completely different person and all
the girls were like who the [ __ ] are you
huh because I had a huge like
breakthrough I had breakdowns on the
show and I changed I became like Cosmo
2.0 a new person so when you separate
yourself from the girl weeks months and
then you come back as a new person you
could build that attraction again it's
the only way to do it so you couldn't so
even if you skip the attraction phase
you can you can go yeah you have to let
her you have to let her wonder about you
she can be looking at your IG stories
every day she has to be like whatever
happened to David whatever happened
Steve whatever happened in Cosmo and you
come back a new person and now you build
that attraction that's so fat I think
that's something that a lot of guys want
to know because that's the purgatory
that a lot of dudes that hit me up they
feel like they're stuck in right and one
of the things that I didn't like was the
personal responsibility thing it's like
you have to set that precedence right
like you don't just end up in the friend
zone there's there is an interaction
that happens cuz I I do know somebody
right now that continually puts himself
in there and I couldn't like describe
what it was right I don't know what it
is but when I see him interact with
women I'm like you're already there like
you're or you're already not they're not
already attracted to you and I think he
kind of confuses oh they're talking to
me all the time so eventually I'll be
able
you know go that way it's like I don't
think so man like you're right here and
I don't know that those words see that's
really interesting cuz I didn't know how
to explain it to him I could just
observe it and be like she's this she's
like let's go out one night and bring
him along and I was going love we should
take some cameras and like recording me
out we should do like another episode
and then let's go out somewhere dude and
you'll be like I'll make you feel
anxious because this should I do you'll
be like Cosmo like literally guys guys
I'm like anchor I gotta see that that's
[ __ ] fascinating man only because
like what I like about this too is the
fact of you're not coming from a point
of [ __ ] I was born with this you
know it was like I'm you I am I am you
so if you think that you can't do it I
was right where you were if you think
about what we've just done in this
episode no dating coach would start how
I started think about how we started
this [ __ ] interview talking about all
man securities what I suck at in life my
my weak points I talked about my mom and
me not having a good relationship you
nailed it bro I'm one of them yeah I'm
not look this is a typical dating coach
I would have sat here with your podcast
it would go to be it to be a confident
guy I got to put my uh they would go
like this to you they would look at they
would like go like this yeah man so yeah
and it would play that game [ __ ] that
game bro I'm gonna be myself when I'm
around like this situation especially I
know you have a big audience so I want
to make sure that I'm one of you guys
right yeah but when I do go out brother
I do have a switch where I turn on yeah
and that's why for me every time I go
out like we go out it's Halloween for me
mm-hmm cuz this is a [ __ ] game bro
mm-hmm girls took an hour and a half to
get ready and they act like they don't
want to talk to any guy brother I get to
the lounge and I'm like this is
Halloween everybody is acting right now
everybody has a costume and you know
what I'm not gonna be myself right now
I'm gonna be a heightened version of
myself I'm gonna be like on fire and
then once we talk right the bar we're
chilling then I go back to be me what a
brother but when I'm gonna approach the
people I'm in character just like you
were when you to stand up I'm in
character
I like that too it's like
yeah if she wasn't here to talk to
anybody why the [ __ ] is she had a bar at
Saturday night dressed up to the [ __ ]
nines and then she goes I don't want to
talk to anybody huh that's right this oh
that's so fascinating that's why at the
end of the day my job is to I go out and
I just want to make people feel better
about themselves but I will be honest
with you brother when there's a girl
that has a big ego or she's treating her
friends like I hear a girl go you look
fat in a dress to her other friend
that's kind of chubby I take it into my
hands to be like I'm gonna I'm gonna
bring you down so much right now you
know like I like a humbling experience
right yeah not like being mad at them
but I'll start to like turn my back
towards them I'll go by her friend a
drink not her I'll start to really make
her feel like this is what you're making
other people feel lonely and isolated
I'm gonna make you feel this right now
so you don't do this to anybody else
yeah so I do go in with strong
intentions of like making sure that at
the end of the conversation I'm like are
you are we both in reality right now
like coz coz coz this is fun like like
you you took two hours to get ready you
do realize that right I can see all the
makeup you look great but why like why
are you doing this yeah
to look for validation is it what like
what in your life is not like who hurt
you right it goes down to that who hurt
you yeah
because if she had a healthy perspective
on man she wouldn't be doing that I know
so many beautiful women that once you
talked to them for more than ten minutes
you're like hey cause my love you bro I
know we're so we're gonna go out tonight
but I can't stay like they give you you
you just get like tension you're like
you're like I can't do this yeah and I'm
like how can they be so beautiful and
then like guys are like I can't be
around him yeah cuz they're so worried
about being perfect if you look I saw a
couple year videos on your Instagram I
gotta watch more but the little that
I've seen from you what I love about
what you do bro is you're very authentic
and that's why I like Gary Vee as well
you have a lot of Gary Vee and you you
just kind of like you don't find the
best camera angle you don't find an
angle that's the most flattering towards
you you don't like your you just talk
and I think that's why you build such a
big audience because you're very
authentic mmm and at the end of the day
like that's what I'm looking for with my
clients they're people that walk up to
me let's say I'm with like seven girls
happens like go out with the girls I
like hanging out with girls more than
guys to be honest with you I I just like
that I'm like you I grew up like kind of
like more feminine energy with my
grandma so I'll go out with girls and if
a guy approaches I'm not a hater at all
I'm like hey what her brother how are
you doing I'm nice man and I give him
time to be like what are you do
yeah and and obviously you know I'm
obsessed with social dynamics so I
wonder what he's gonna do right now yeah
yeah and then if you [ __ ] up I'm gonna
give you my business card guys come on
and they have good vibes because I could
see their intention and they're very
respectful but they're also like dude
you know I came out to talk to girls
they don't ignore me which is a good
technique under and they address me I'm
the only guy mmm and I'm like well
played so I'll stay quiet they have no
idea who I am
yeah what I can do and I'm just like
stay quiet and I'm and if he wants the
number exchanged with a girl dude I'm
fine with it
yeah totally open am i okay in your
opinion um how much do looks play a part
of this right before a guy anyways
because um you know what sometimes like
I see I'll look at them up I'll see
their Facebook or their email photo I'm
like you know you probably couldn't you
know get a haircut or some [ __ ] like
that you know guy you nailed it it's not
about two looks it's about how they take
care of themselves like they groom I've
seen okay so let me rewind do looks
matter absolutely does money matter
absolutely I would be so dumb to be like
oh if you don't like money looks don't
matter they will always give you an
advantage but when I learned this art
form as soon as I got out of the show I
text all my model friends they know who
they are like good-looking guys and I'm
like they don't know I have this art
form because I want when I went under
reality show no one knew where I went oh
I couldn't say anything cuz I won fifty
thousand so if anybody would find out a
vh1 would pull the money from me I just
came back and people are like where'd
you bro some people are like did you go
to India for a retreat
what did you do I'm like nine just
they're like bro you're different and
why I what what ended up happening was I
would go out with my really like male
model friends and they would always
start ahead of me right yeah we'd go out
and then a girl would always like look
at a how are you and but then with the
game that I had it was consistent and I
would always end up winning at the end
which would like win over the girl or
the girls were getting invited back to
their place and like the looks could
only take you so far as my point mm-hmm
but the girl women and all the women
listening we are gonna like kind of
anchor to this women don't care how you
look they care how you think you look
I've seen very unattractive guys carry
themselves very confidently cuz they're
like dude I'm gonna you know I am to
[ __ ] you know I'm I'm the [ __ ] and this
is what I believe
so women feel that they don't take more
care about like how do you think you
look that's why and also too we have to
break it down scientifically
unfortunately for women they for us
looks do matter a lot more than for them
to us because our number one need is sex
to replicate like we want a girl that's
gonna turn us on that looks good and the
other way around I've seen a lot of
beautiful women would not so attractive
men but the men can provide their number
one need which is protection hmm so then
they you see a lot of relationships out
in the world where it's a beautiful girl
and then a guy driving a Lambo or
Mercedes and he's got that crime will
need its the primal need and when people
are like he's a gold digger I'm like you
just don't know anything about
psychology or you don't know anything
about like this is the way we're
genetically hardwired this way like
she's gonna go with the guy that can
protect her children yeah right yeah so
then that's also too that's why fighting
is such a big attraction trigger with
women like I'm sure you have a lot of
comedy videos on your Instagram but I
saw a video where you were kicking and
punching yeah automatically women see
that there's an attraction trigger that
goes on just in case you go out with any
girls we know that he can protect us
[ __ ] Latino women who cares that's my
man like listen listen be quiet that
buff [ __ ] is huge
dude so yeah I mean looks matter more
for women and we see it in Hollywood you
know so many women that were the best
actresses 20s and 30s when I get to
their 40s or 50s they don't get the
roles that the guys do the guys could
still be leading man at 50 55 you know
you're a little easy we have so many
what is it like j.lo and like a handful
but all the other actresses that are
passed 40 45 it's [ __ ] up but they
kind of get like benched
no is so interesting man and I think you
kind of nailed it on the head too it's
like it's more of a perception of how a
guy feels like he looks like I say this
till this day like I didn't know until
about two years ago I was like 280
pounds Wow I was a big boy right I
didn't know I was fat I had no [ __ ]
idea if I mean I was just chilling right
and you know I didn't really I was
always in basketball shorts and a
t-shirt even when I would do these
collars showing these stand-up shows I
didn't really dress up like I just went
out but I always felt like I not like I
didn't have anything to offer right and
I think that whether it was a confidence
trigger once again I always put it back
to me doing stand-up and you know Kent
trying to get rid of my anxiety that way
I just always never felt like I had too
much of a disadvantage cuz I could
always just kind of either talk to or do
something with it right so I never felt
like I was out of shape or I wasn't
attractive you know when I went into
these like social social situations and
even my fiancee said that about me too
and you were when I when I first met you
you were like you were very confident
and she goes I actually didn't know you
were overweight until you mentioned it
to me Wow yeah and I think it's also
maybe because I'm taller too there's a
lot of other reasons too but even my
friends to this day they're like yeah
man like I didn't know you were a
overweight guy until you started losing
weight how much you weigh right now I'm
like 210 she's lost 70 pounds yeah and
for me it was it was never like a looks
thing it was it was a health thing
because you know once I hit I'm like 31
32 now so once I hit about like 30
oh [ __ ] like am i fat person I started
feeling it right I couldn't play ball I
couldn't do a lot of this other [ __ ] and
you know I took kickboxing when I was 20
I wasn't good at it but you know in my
mind I thought I was dope with my
[ __ ] you know confident that said I
took a kickboxing class and I recorded
myself and I was like I bet you these
[ __ ] punches are gonna be the fastest
[ __ ] thing you've ever
scene and I saw the clip I was like what
the [ __ ] is this and I still have those
clips to this day just to remind myself
like hey you're not as dope as you
thought you were right and so I you know
I started feeling a lot of health issues
and I like that's why I lost weight but
that's so interesting I do believe you
kind of hit the nail on the head it's
it's more about how a guy feels like he
looks versus what he actually looks like
100% and you kind of nailed one more
thing that a lot of people don't talk
about was with my homegirl yesterday at
Hermosa and we're talking about and
she's like what what like cuz whatever
dude I go out with a lot of girls oh by
the way we haven't talked about it I got
out of a ten-year relationship and went
through a crazy divorce so [ __ ] and
that's a that's was pretty amazing like
I loved every part of it and I kind of
in a weird way as I'm driving to your
podcast today I'm like I had an epiphany
as I was driving here I go I think I
kind of wanted that hmm in a dark way
I'm like I wanted to experience that
because I coach so many guys over the
years about how to get over heartbreak
and you got to do this you got to do
that a part of me felt like a fraud I'm
wrong I want to experience this I want
to see if I'm if I can do it so I don't
know if I'm right or wrong I'm just like
telling you how I felt
you're just like driving over here going
I talk about it in a podcast but I I was
like I've done everything now write like
pick up girls when I Stan's 10-year
relationship we cried on national TV
learned it like I've done everything so
like as far as like emotional
intelligence like this guy has so much
empathetic qualities cuz he sucks and
and he and we were both talking about
earlier like anxiety like like let's
open a forum like what like what's the
problem here you know what I mean like
like I feel like the people who are
leading this world right now that are
the most likeable people are the most
easiest people to read and the most
empathetic people and if people who are
like hiding behind so many filters and
all of that like America just doesn't
really like grab onto them that much you
know in the video you called out that
girl dude I love that you did that and I
don't know if you want talking about now
but yeah that all lives matter thing
where she was like oh my god Irie and
she made the whole video about herself
yeah you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
I love that you did that because I'm
like you're gonna use your platform and
she had a lot of followers right and I'm
like really I'm a user platform to do
that so anytime I have a platform like
this to come on your podcast I just want
to empower people to be like bro it's
okay to talk about your quote/unquote
weaknesses because that's what makes you
a beast that's what makes you like
different do you know like one of my
favorite UFC fighters of all time is
George st. Pierre and he had that post
recently just talking about all of his
failures and for some reason watching
somebody of that caliber speak like that
it empowered me like a [ __ ] right
he was like let me show you the first
time that I ever wrestled I got pinned
in like three seconds the first time I
ever went into juice is I got choked out
in a few seconds and now this is the guy
who was who right now is probably
considered one of the best
pound-for-pound fighters in the world
right for when he was active and just to
hear him talk about his flaws and how
bad he was before how he was a victim of
bullying somehow made me feel great you
know yeah I love when he's like yeah
they're like you get nervous he's like
I'm gonna go in the cage and then locked
up he's like I get nervous you know so I
love what you just said cuz they're real
fighters the authentic ones even Nate
Diaz right you know like Nate Diaz like
[ __ ] yeah get scared I want to [ __ ]
fight you know like it's just scary I
get anxiety that's real talk right there
that's like that's why you know he's
like the baddest [ __ ] or
whatever cuz that's like he made Diaz
for those of you that don't know he just
thought George Mazda doll he lost but he
really didn't like he got he went out of
that fight a winner yeah you know like
because of that like quality of just
being so real man like yeah it's it's
very appealing and you and you have that
and you have that thank you do you have
anybody that you've ever coached that
was uncoachable yeah people that think
that they don't need help and that
they're coming to my [ __ ] seminar
because they just want to check me out
or their friend said whatever or a bro
yeah what up Cosmo Big Finish oh man so
yeah man I'm living Dubai I got a couple
car they start talking to me about how
much money they got and all that by the
way brother I'm doing this for my
roommate you know London you know what I
mean we got a rooftop and condo in
London you can come out and visit
I'm like brother what so like what do
you want to learn he's like no I don't
wanna learn anything is from my roommate
so those people oh my god the ego and
most of them are like club promoters
that they'll come to me they'll pay me
the money and then they'll be like nah
that's not for me bro you know how I get
down
and I'm like actually I don't know how
you get down cuz any girl that you get
they're always at your table you always
have to do so many favors for them and
then they'll get drunk and maybe have a
one-night stands with you like you don't
have the cojones to go to Santa Monica
Pier and just walk up to strangers yeah
so yeah do you in your case to for I
mean when you have guys like that I mean
that's what you're talking about when it
comes to like ego like it's like when
they go it's for my friend is like the
[ __ ] it's for you so like somebody
like that do you do you take the steps
to break down their ego or is it just
like this is impossible
like how does that even work my ego
thinks that I could break them down
because I'm like I think I'm one of the
best dating coaches in the world and I
and I've seen a lot of them and so yeah
so my ego is fully intact I'm like I'm
gonna break just like Eagles going at it
but at a certain point yeah man I broken
a lot of them and usually it'll come
like write a club and they're like I got
to go to the bathroom and I'll grab the
wrist will get bro we'll get like a
little feisty and you know and he's like
don't touch me I'm like I'm gonna touch
you as you're gonna do yeah I'm gonna go
talk to girls right now it's not I'm
like right now bruh I'm like right now
and so I have to and then they do it and
cut they come after and then they're
like [ __ ] you don't ever do that and
then I'll get a text being like hey come
out to club real quick I come out there
in tears going man I've never felt
better in my life
thank you you know there's a there has
to be that breaking point that breaking
point where they're like I'm done hiding
I'm done writing YouTube comments or
Instagram comments and then blooding and
blocking David so you won't see me
you're blocking this person you know
what I mean like they hide and when you
have nowhere to hide when you have
someone like a coach like hold you
liable and they break down that's it
makes me feel alive dude I'm like oh
yeah it's interesting cuz you're you
know I think when people hear the term
pickup artist right they they kind of
picture like a sleaze ball almost right
if I asked like the girls I'll pick up
artists like I'll he's just trying to
get into my pants but you're more like a
life coach man is so funny you said that
because I'm just starting for the first
time ever like pretty we're launching
with we have good money behind us and
these guys that are like marketing
geniuses saw me talk and they're like
are you millionaire I'm like hail know
they're like bro you need to be making
online products or you need to be doing
more seminars and they know that they're
like we feel like you're more than the
dating coach like you talk about you're
like doing a lot more than that so I'm
like I told you when we walked in here
man I don't have any pickup artist
friends all my friends are actors
filmmakers artists fighters comedians
like these are the people hang out with
ya cuz like we have everything that
you're telling me right now it doesn't
sound you know for me to what I was
expecting right cuz you sound definitely
more like a life coach you're actually
digging deeper than I think most people
would think that you would because it's
not just the here's the pickup line this
is what you're gonna do to get inside
this girl's pants it's more like why are
you the way that you are you know let's
let's break down this ego first and see
where you're at because it's not the
girls problem is it's a you problem
there's some there's a certain level of
personal responsibility that you have to
take on and I don't think a lot of guys
want to take like that guy right there
when he was like I'm gonna go to the
bathroom decide I know why you want to
go to the bathroom I know cuz you're
trying to hide right now so cut that
[ __ ] out and go and do it and to see
what happens 100% I think that I work
from the outside in I know like other
people with meditation they work from
the inside out so let me explain what I
mean I work outward inwardly meaning
that if the guy can approach 35 girls
today that's an that's active is not
passive and it's not inner it's not
meditation yoga he's going out getting a
drink in his face getting rejected
you're ugly you're fat he's feeling that
and that outwardness that him doing it
over and over and then he he'll hook a
girl she's like yeah I like it and
they'll start talking he gets the number
that goes inward and he goes to bed
going well god damn I could do this and
that to me is how I work so I worked the
other way around the other way around a
lot of people work in word out word I
word
outward inward so you come to me and the
guys like you'll have major approach
anxiety and dissing that before were
twenty minutes into it I never tell them
I'm like put on your shoes they're like
what are you doing I'm like we're going
out right now and you're gonna walk up
to fifty girls and you're gonna walk up
to him say I'm trying to pick you up my
name is Enrique I'm about to tell you
pickup lines
hold on oh [ __ ] I just saw you from over
here earlier and I wanted to cook just
like that because I'm holy [ __ ]
brother I'm I'm not gonna spend and I
know like there's a lot of good people
at my palm cos I love I love I love fear
people are like wait you're so weird I'm
like bro I love fear fear propels me to
amazing places and if it wasn't for fear
like I would be when I wasn't walking
into a lot of fear like yeah that was
weak nothing wrong with weed but for me
it kills everything for me and numbs me
out so I was like smoking weed in the
morning and I was just like kind of like
numbing myself and now I'm like what am
I scared of right now I'm gonna go
attack that so by the fact that they
there's a demon behind me and most
people are like let's not talk about it
let's not talk about let's not talk
about it I'm like bro
turn around and ask that demon yo you
want to take a shot of vodka with me
let's party bro like make him your
[ __ ] friend so you're scared of
approach anxiety I'm gonna take you to
the highest level were you gonna walk up
to girls and say you're picking them up
and you're gonna take out a paper that I
that I wrote for you you're gonna say it
and once they do that they're like did I
get stabbed
nope did I get shot nope well that
wasn't as bad tomorrow now I'm gonna
know a lot more that Cosmo taught me and
that bet is gonna be better holy Sh I
don't start with baby steps bro I start
with get off the plane hold so when so
when you had a client right and then you
told them like all right let's go and
let's get what was her reaction like
like how do they usually perceive that
cuz I'm nervous for them dude like just
to go up to somebody and be like boom
this is who I am here it is
you know tell you there's a whole list
of these pickup lines I'm getting
nervous
hey bro yeah I mean I thanks Cosmo yeah
well I'm down and dude tomorrow
I'm you know I just uh I got a headache
oh hey Cosmo I like what you're doing
bro you know like I know what you're
trying to do but let's do it next time
baby steps hey Cosmo uh nah man I'm good
I just need all of that [ __ ] don't mean
nut and get your shoes on we're going
right now
holy crap and so that's just that's not
to say like these pickup lines are gonna
work it's just more it's some more a
self healing thing then at that point
absolutely but ironically enough when
they come that transparent that
authentic even if they're not what I
call attraction triggers the girl pauses
and a girl laughs and it happens a lot
of girls like you q what's your name
yeah Steve it's like Steve Wow and the
group kind of like is like yeah it
doesn't go anywhere you know cuz the
girls like there's not a guy that it you
know yeah I'm gonna make but they kind
of pause some of them get creeped out by
the way I'm not saying the show works
I'm just like get out of here weirdo but
some of them kind of pause and go wow
that was interesting that was creative
holy [ __ ] yeah I want to see that so
[ __ ] bad not with me see it just
because you know I talk about the
probability game a lot right but even
being open like that it frightens me a
little bit cuz even though I don't have
a plan I do know that I had my humor you
know that I can kind of like segue into
or something right but to be that
vulnerable is pretty [ __ ] frightening
and then once they plowed through that
then something then if the energy comes
within and there's really good people
like I'm working with my buddy Josh Cole
he's doing an amazing thing called alive
and well with Jay Shetty and Lucy Hall
and Jay Shetty is like all in word and
Josh's my good friend is trying to
involve me because I teach outward Jay
Shetty's like inward meditation I'm like
outward go move move move and then
inside I'm looking for competence not
confidence I'm just looking for the guy
to be like okay I got one number today
I'm 31 years old
I've never gotten a number something
that this crazy Cuban guy Cosmo is doing
is working I'm all-in whatever he tells
me I'm
gonna do they wake up the next morning I
look at him in my seminar they got their
shoulders back you're like with some
[ __ ] I'm like oh we don't go
talk to 30 girls and now that it now
that it doesn't scare them now I don't
do it ya know now we're gonna learn
technique cuz I believed them now it
doesn't scare them cuz they're like bro
we already went through hell and back so
now what you got let's go talk to them
like no I'm gonna change it on you it's
like okay well you got rejected 30 times
that number down a little bit are there
any what are some like people that
you've worded that you could talk about
like who's who some people that you've
worked with
I have NTAs how do you like how many
people have you worked with yeah I mean
celebrities I have a lot of NDA's cuz um
yeah of course yeah yeah yeah but I
could I could tell you I'm I work with
dan Bilzerian fur Jerry yeah it's on you
it's on yeah oh I'll show you this you
for no no no so he has a CBD thing
called ignite mm-hm and he in my opinion
attacked the wrong platform in my
opinion he did on a twitch okay yeah but
a lot of had people on Twitter just like
horny little [ __ ] going on so
it wasn't a right platform for it but he
brought me in as someone that hosted a
show with three really cool girls
they're all have a lot of followers and
yeah yeah hire or whatever and um so I
was at his house a lot and work with
their company for months and months and
um it was beautiful I was like did you
fast like gamblers yeah you got money
and everything but think about this and
is a really big like well let me just
start by saying this when is the last
time that you think that Dan Bilzerian
walked up to a complete group of
strangers that didn't know who he was
and that he didn't get the girls brought
to him you see that's the void that's a
big void there not knowing that if you
could ever do that it's the same void
that I know a lot of kids that their dad
are big celebrities a lot of them and
they walk around with this void cuz
they'll never know if they can make it
on their own yeah your dad is XY and Z
see he has that like when's the last
time he was able to really do that so
he's orchestrated his life where women
come up to him and
kudos and Bravo to him and that's what
he does oh but there's something up like
I'll show you the clip when I first met
him like he didn't shake my hand we're
doing a show in the second floor of his
house I don't know how many floors he
has and then they're like before I want
to see Cosmo bring him to the rooftop so
when you go on a livestream oh it's all
livestream by the way - so some moments
were awkward and all that but I walk up
and he's just sitting there with a bunch
of girls and doesn't say hi to me
doesn't give me the handshake and I go
I'm very good at this game I can play
this game all day and I'm not gonna
stand there bro so as soon as I saw them
like oh he's gonna play this game I'm
like a low-value guy that's very
reactive would be like hey you told me
to come here now you're not shaking my
hand never be reactive but just be self
aware
oh he's playing this game so I literally
started to introduce myself to all his
girls just hey what's up Cosmo great
energy I started talking to all his
girls and he loved and in that moment he
enjoyed that moment he enjoyed he
started clapping he's like this
[ __ ] you brought this
[ __ ] to take my girls and he
laughed and I opened it up because I'm
like I'm gonna make fun of the fact that
you brought me up here and now you're
not talking to me I'm making fun of the
fact that we're doing this now and then
for the rest of the episode it was great
vibes and um he heard me talk a little
bit and in that moment I made 10 grand
he's like I hears ya I'm gonna give you
10 grand go coach guys and help him out
and I had to focus because he's from
like the army or whatever yeah I had to
pick guys that had PTSD but just hearing
meeting Dan [ __ ] gave me 10 grand I
was [ __ ] crazy and I think dude I
rather have an authentic again what you
do really well he's authentic as [ __ ]
he's not trying to hide I'd rather him
than a Hollywood producer that's like oh
yes god is good or distant come to my
house party and they make comedies like
I rather you know what you're gonna get
with Dan you know what you're gonna get
with you it's not like to face and I
enjoy those people if you do you also
teach that like authenticity to your
clients as well because I feel sometimes
because I I think like for you I guess
that you're saying you know when you go
out and you're in these social social
areas you have to turn on this switch
right but it's still a like an authentic
version of yourself that you're trying
to be right
it's a heightened version of myself it's
the same thing as you doing stand-up
it's just a hind version of myself I'm
aware that I have a microphone and need
to make people laugh so I need to be
funny right now like you can't be like
that like for audience cuz then you know
there's a healthy balance when I go out
and I'm like [ __ ] these people I'm gonna
have a good time but then there's
another part where like well I got to
entertain people I'm getting paid to
like talk to people so it is a hind
version jut the best analogy I can give
is when a celebrity goes on a talk show
it's a heightened version of them have a
live audience they know they gotta be
charismatic and for those people that
don't believe in pickup lines think
about the most likable person that you
like and I know a lot of people might
say Tom Hanks Tom Hanks has pre recorded
stories memorized hmmm let's talk about
Tom Hanks he's likable why is there such
a bad stigma on having memorized stories
why you look at Tom Hanks I'll break
down clips
he went to four different talk shows and
he has the same story cuz he knows that
that story's gonna bill laughter you
guys stand up comedians you guys [ __ ]
perform the same story and go to another
club and do it why can't I coach my guys
to do that every time that I go yeah my
dog's name is Rambo and I have like a
story it it hits every time why wouldn't
I want to why would I want that
organized in my in my head why wouldn't
I want like that prepared I'm already
going to war with five models two girls
that are having a bad day and two guys
that are fighters and one Hollywood
promoter I'm already at war where
they're like who is this I want it at
least have a game plan oh [ __ ] I never
thought about it like that you I do
defend yeah I do defend pick-up lines I
do defend having pre-recorded stories
but I but I don't defend lying and being
sleazy about it always be your true self
you know so I'm gonna give you a really
good technique for those of you that are
not making that much money and where
you're at in your life and you're like
Cosmo but I can't pick up girls because
I don't even have a car and I'm living
in my mom's basement here's what you do
you talk about your future
oh and that's how you
demonstrate higher value and that's how
you showcase this other side of yourself
that you want to attract that girl you
think Steve Jobs in his when he was
making in his garage was like yeah I'm
in a garage hell no he was like I'm
gonna have the biggest [ __ ] company
ever
Mark Zuckerberg all these people when
you they're talking about the future so
when you're talking to a beautiful girl
you don't have to feel fake if you're
like you start here's the pick-up line I
can't wait until done so you're like
yeah I mean my buddy Cosmo doing a
podcast and I can't wait until my
startup company starts I have a lot of
investors I'm really excited that I'm
gonna so and you start to talk about
your future yeah you see now that builds
the attraction huh see this is this is
so interesting because I think like what
I like about this too is there's
definitive points to jump off of cuz
you're right I was like your homegirls
where I was just like oh [ __ ] do it
well you were saying that when I walked
in here you when we were walking in your
house oh [ __ ] like what does that do for
somebody like how how could I just look
at somebody and say well you know be
calm what the [ __ ] does that mean you
know so to give people some definitive
points to really jump off of probably
gives them that self-confidence to is
like at least I know where to [ __ ]
start 100% anybody that's ever felt
depressed think about somebody coming up
to you and go just be happy oh it's the
worst [ __ ] thing you can tell
depressed person hmm why don't just be
happy
cut be happy David what's wrong with you
it's the worst thing you could tell
someone
somebody's depressed you go to me and go
um I'm here oh you gotta say I'm here if
you want to talk bro I'm here I'm just
gonna show your couch you don't to talk
to me and you're depressed right let's
say you're going through whatever and I
just chill with you bro and I'm on my
phone I'm not interrogating I'm not
trying to fix you and I'm just me being
there the person's like okay don't try
to fix them don't try to do anything
just cool man cool brother I don't even
know how you feel right now but I love
you so I'm here so whatever you need me
to do I'll punch myself in the face yeah
that's what that's emotional
intelligence which is another thing we
don't talk about we talk about IQ and
people who are really
smart I've seen the dumbest people with
high accuse like making the dumbest
mistakes ever getting into a marriage
three months cuz his girl wanted papers
and he got like 400 grand taken away
from him in a divorce and he hired a
hooker I'm like how what's your IQs like
137 I'm like so your society tells you
you're a genius bro yeah you're [ __ ]
idiot dude yeah let's start putting EQ
in it like emotional intelligence needs
to be talked about more oh sure and
there's some of our leaders locked at
big time yeah don't tell just part two I
like I I do agree I think a lot of my
I'm gonna say well I guess some of my
friends to their their incense it's like
you look at what they have right as a
business career and everything else it's
it's fantastic so you people kind of
take their IQ and they think that it
translates to their EQ right it's like
well if you're this intelligent here
you're gonna be just as smart over here
but then I've you know I've talked to
these certain friends and you know when
we get to know each other you started
hearing a lot of their emotional problem
that they're having in their
relationships and in my mind just like
you said it was like what the [ __ ] don't
you know that is it I think that they're
unaware or they're just deflecting or
what do you think the top like two or
three reasons are with your friends that
are you know one of them I just found
out that he's kind of just um he's
somebody who's a little too literal
right and he's just always been like
he's like the definitive like guy guy
things are just face value and that's it
so when he hears some stuff like hey if
is like his girlfriend at the time was
like okay like I'm really sleeping today
leave me alone he goes she's tired and
she probably stayed up was like or maybe
something else is bothering her he
doesn't he just takes everything at face
value so a lot of their emotional
problems he can't hear what she's asking
for because he's only hearing the exact
words you know and I think that's what
happens a lot I feel like we should talk
about this form an emotional
intelligence we tell we tapped on that
self-awareness and then having electives
for middle school in high school in
college on how to deal with women how to
approach women getting instant feedback
in the classroom like we've been taught
that in class for middle school I had to
do an essay memorized and then in front
of everyone why can't we get a guy and
go okay so girls that are here what's a
good what can I
to walk up to you I think I'm gonna say
lunch cafeteria and open his forum you
know yeah you nailed it
he's very literal it's the worst thing
that you can be if you want a girl for a
lot of years in your life you he will
never keep a girl happy if all he's
coming at it is logical and rational my
advice to him is find a guy partner cuz
if it's two guys I'm mom be stirrers I'm
not trying to joke like if you're gay
right like two guys they can be logical
as [ __ ] both understand and there's
no problem with that because they're
they're not operating how women operate
emotion and intuition so if the girls
telling you like I'm tired right so then
my response is like cool do you want me
to make you a tent or let me let me
serve you some food or do you want any
cozy fear I'm gonna go get you a blanket
from Target you see how I'm like like
I'm activating that part where she's
like this is cool and I'm like yeah I'll
make you a little ten I'll put pillows
you're tired you know get some rest and
then a girl will go yeah yeah I'm tired
I mean you know I'm just frustrated you
didn't ask me that last week and then
I'm like there it is yeah there's a
problem I go ask you what last week yeah
you know when we were my parents and now
I can get to the problem and now I can
either go my bad I apologize I wasn't
aware of it mm-hmm and we move on yeah
as simple as it is yeah that's that's a
hard part cuz I think even for me when I
I didn't realize I did this and
obviously maybe if I thought two years
ago I would have gone to this because I
didn't I didn't realize that you know
when she would let's say my fiancee at
the time right she would say certain
things like that and you know my
response is to well why don't you just
tell me you know but then because I
always expected things to be laid out
for me all the time and it's just kind
of it's unfair for me to expect that out
of her right because there are certain
things about me that's the way that I am
there's certain things about her that's
the way that she is and I wasn't really
bending towards that and so sometimes
like in those type of situations I
understood what he was saying cuz I was
like I did that too you know it's as
sometimes when i if I had to do that
where I'm like oh do you want me to get
you a coffee or whatever I don't know if
it's because I grew up in a very strict
Asian Korean household would that you
know that Asian machismo type of [ __ ] it
made me feel like I was it was taking
away from me if you were to ask
like let me get you a coffee yeah made
me feel like I was in servitude almost
like that's like kind of [ __ ] really it
felt very I don't know what it was like
I had this epiphany later on it's like
why does it feel like when I'm giving to
somebody I care about like her that I
love it feels like I'm taking away from
me like I I had that moment where I was
like how do you do that
like don't you care about her so why
does it make you feel like you're like
the little [ __ ] in the relationship
where it's like I'm serving you all the
time but really it's more like you care
about her she's hurting help her you
know and I had that weird moment I'm
like you you're kind of mean dude you
know you're gonna mean to her like why
do you why do you do that because in my
mind I'm like well you can get it
yourself
you know but it's like but that's not
the point you know why do you do this is
early on in the relationship but you
know when I had that moment I felt very
I felt terrible you know yeah and then
you have if I was to debate myself right
now like to contradict myself I would be
like but if you're to like maybe I'll
please you baby I please yeah she's
gonna get bored and cheat on you oh for
sure no that part of you that is edgy
and like [ __ ] get yourself you know
like that that's attractive to her like
I can never really get off my man and I
still feel like I haven't got yeah like
I love it when people go I'm in a
relationship I don't need to play those
games or like I don't I don't want to
please games just want to be myself I'm
like good [ __ ] luck yeah because the
games never stop brawls in a 10-year
relationship with a very competitive
person okay and we didn't have more than
two arguments in like the first four
years bro oh [ __ ] like everybody was
like you guys are kind of perfect
together like I was just diffused
everything she always got where I'm
coming from I would have come home if
you see this is so rare and then like I
had a bad day I'm like have a [ __ ]
really bad day I'm cranky I'm gonna be a
little [ __ ] right now if I'm mad at you
my bad
now she's in on your game she's like
okay you know what I mean rather than
like you come in and she's like baby
alright and then the guys like yeah I'm
alright why why do you why do you ask me
that yeah yeah yeah you know what I mean
rather just like lay out lay out the
cards but I mean the game's never
stopped mmm what people they
healthy thing in my opinion is to
associate positive behavior with the
games
why does playing games have to be a bad
thing why can't it be a fun thing I
can't be like it like yeah man we're
still playing games you know I see I
went to Vegas and I met a couple that
was together for like 60 years drunk off
my ass bros like 3:00 in the morning I
lost my friends and if I I don't even
smoke cigarettes and I'm smoking assayer
I'm like what am i doing and I start
talking he's [ __ ] to old people I've
been in relationship and he still got
that sexual tension they're still
pulling they're still playing games I'm
like it's not never gonna end
yeah like yeah I made him breakfast but
he doesn't like my broccoli he's very
hard to you know you still playing that
game yeah it's kind of exciting yeah I
think just to go back to your previous
point too is like when people you know
the hottest word right now is a simp
right and I you know I honestly don't
know what that is so I can sip is the
guy that just kind of well it really
depends I can definitively it's a guy
that gives everything to the girl puts
her on a pedestal but gets nothing in
return right and that that is the
relationship that makes him quote
unquote happy but I have a relative who
I think is kind of like a simp to but
with him like I had a conversation with
him and when he when he when his
relationship kind of fell apart right
one of the things that he said when he
told me when he opened up was I gave
everything to her right every anything
she asked for I gave everything to her
and what I told him to was what that
kind of broke my heart is because just
because you give what they asked doesn't
mean that they'll stay doesn't mean they
respect you it doesn't mean any of that
stuff right and that's the bestest sad
part about like the simp thing right you
think that if you give them riches you
give them gold you give everything else
that they'll stick around just because
you give them what they asked for and
that's not in my opinion like I don't
know how to put into words but that's
not how it is
you know you nailed it if you want to
break down love love is three components
passion intimacy and commitment passion
intimacy and commitment it is impossible
to be in a long-term relationship and
hold three out of three one of those
[ __ ] are going out the window
quick and maybe it'll come back really
good marriages have two out of three
most marriages on planet Earth
have one out of three hmm so you have to
think to yourself in the relationship
that you're in right now in a
relationship whoever is watching this
right so you're in a relationship right
and you go wait I mean I'm hearing this
[ __ ] Cosmo talk and he kind of makes
sense so passion intimacy and commitment
if you have the bad-boy type as a girl
you have like that guy that's edgy and
that guy that has a lot of girlfriends
and you know I mean there's always a
little bit of jealousy there it's a
healthy thing cuz that passion is there
like I can't I can slip up I can gain 40
pounds my man will leave me that's
healthy right some people don't have
that passion they only have the
commitment so it's one out of three
where the girl will go my husband will
never cheat on me and will never leave
me
he works in nine or seven he never goes
out I know he's not gonna cheat on me
and no girl would want him so the girl
has a commitment and the guy has a
commitment from her you see what I mean
yeah yeah well we won't cheat on each
other but the passion is out the [ __ ]
window and the intimacy is barely there
you know what I mean yeah so like
actively working on like what is one
that's gonna be really hard to to take
away right and for me to be honest with
you in my ten-year relationship the
commitment things started fading quick
I'm passionate as [ __ ] so the sex was
good unpredictability on my end would
always keep her on her feet the intimacy
I like to cuddle man I like to talk
about my emotions I like I was grew up
on my grandma I'd like to be intimate
but the commitment you see on my end
could have been stronger I never cheated
on her but just a commitment on like I
don't know I can I can explain it but it
was like fading mm-hmm so like I had to
work on that and then it ended up being
like just a passion on our relationship
which is no bueno
it is like one out of three is your
passion like fireworks gonna happen and
they did oh [ __ ] that's interesting
because I might the relationship that I
had prior to my fiancee now she was
somebody that I was very committed to
but I had zero passion and I think it's
because of you know when I would ask for
her opinion on something right she would
I agree baby I agree yeah I think I
think it's great like what do you think
that's exactly what it was and it was
killing me cuz I was like I don't know
you like
your thoughts are you just agreeing with
me just to agree she was perfectly fine
right very sweet girl she was cute
everything I enjoyed about her and just
that killed the passion though cuz I
felt like I couldn't I didn't know her
you know I mean I didn't know what what
lit her fire was it is what is your fire
just to agree with everything that I
have like I need to know you you know
and I think that killed it for me
imagine watching a movie where the
protagonist doesn't have any conflict we
would be bored to death
we loved to watch great movies where
it's like conflict tension conflict he's
married oh my god don't hire that
assistant she's beautiful all you did oh
[ __ ] you're going out to Dubai with her
oh [ __ ] like we in narrative feature
films we love tension and conflict bad
movies don't have it huh that's so true
that's that's that's exactly young man
you just [ __ ] it is right cuz when I
went back to it and I kept you know
conversing with it and there was a time
to like and I felt maybe even on her
hand because the the passion wasn't
there to like you mentioned that
jealousy thing right I had zero jealousy
for her oh she is My Mind's blown
because like with her so there was this
conversation that we had and I didn't
realize that how angry had made her made
her because she went to Vegas right and
for me I'm you know relatively confident
dude like you go to Vegas have fun
whatever but I you know she got really
pissed at me because when she went to
Vegas I told her all right have fun just
let me know when you get there and that
kind of left it at that but I think what
she wanted from me was you know make
sure that you're careful make sure okay
stay away from somebody and I didn't do
any of that [ __ ] and so when she came
back she was pissed at me and in my mind
I didn't get it I was like don't you
want a guy that just is like this
doesn't like [ __ ] crowd you or you
know is the jealous type but she did
want a little bit of it because the
passion wasn't there it was very evident
ah the easiest way to find out if a
girl's attracted to you is a theory that
I call a jealousy plotline where if you
really want to know if there's
attraction there you want to see if
she's gonna get jealous cuz if she
doesn't at all then you're in a friend
zone or you your passion is gone and
there's nothing there you
a really quick way to see if a girl's
into you is jealousy people always
attach that to negative things it's a
very positive thing if you use it in in
the right way yeah do you want to feel
that you want to be out with your girl
be like if I leave her in the bathroom
miss you might come back to guys like
you want to feel a little bit of that
you want you know you want to be like oh
she's being pursued by other people I
feel jealous or damn sure what she said
it was brilliant and you read more books
like you go you want to feel a little
bit of that ah that's so interesting you
just kind of like made me relive
something and then kind of rethink it
cuz I always because I'm prior to this
conversation to me it was like why was
she like that like what the [ __ ] you
what you should want a guy that allows
you to do whatever it's like no it's
like bro she could sense that you were
passionate about her and that could
probably killed her and sign a little
bit oh I should finally email and be
like I'm my bad oh [ __ ] I forgot now I
kinda understand where she's coming from
oh [ __ ] what would you say in your
relationship is the two that you have I
mean if you're willing to state three
out of three that's that's cool but I
gave you the stats earlier but what do
you think you you thrive off in your
current relationship it's a passion into
intimacy and commitment it's probably a
passion and commitment got it those are
the two ones the audit the intimacy
thing is the one that I'm working on the
most got it and that's because of what
you're saying you're God in the end like
um you were raised you said your parents
okay cuz you know I've never really saw
my parents like that they were always
working all the time yeah so the
intimacy factor is something that was is
something that I'm learning like I I had
the hardest time just kind of put
bringing my walls down a little bit
so she's somebody who's she emotes a lot
right so when when she when I come in
through the door she wants me to say
good morning how are you give her a big
hug and me I didn't grow up seeing that
stuff so when I just walk in I go and I
get a glass you know and for her to eat
her up a little bit so I'm really
working on that part a lot it's hard for
me and I keep telling her it's like just
just know that I'm always trying cuz
it's hard to describe to her but it's
like pulling teeth with me that's what
it feels like sometimes when I have to
be openly
intimate and it eats away at me for some
reason welcome to what it's like yeah I
would be careful on her end and just and
I have a low by the way I coach a lot of
girls as well yeah like a lot and my
advice about if I didn't know you and
she's like yeah I feel like I'm losing
my guy one of the qualities that I would
tell her to be careful with a guy like
you is pushing him too much to open up
because it's a dangerous thing because
the guy can flip on you and be like I'm
in Vegas right now and I've and and vibe
out with a girl or I'm in London at a
film premiere so you got to be really
careful as a girl to like ask too much
from your man to be emotional it's like
us asking a girl to be extremely logical
it's gonna [ __ ] irritate the [ __ ] out
of them I'm gonna give you a perfect
example my student she was a girl I told
her I just laid out this is a good one
she got out of the airport and LAX her
man said I was gonna I'm gonna pick you
up I'll be there but on a 405 going
south to get to LAX there was a huge car
accident and he has ways so he's like oh
[ __ ] is blocked like an hour and a half
mind you he could have taken all the
streets and all that but it would but it
was like I think he told me an hour and
a half on the way from LAX back to there
in the hills it was like 27 minutes
logically he was like I'm gonna order
her an uber XL whatever and bring her
here why would I Drive an hour and a
half this accident I know it's there and
then come back logically who makes more
sense he does you know emotionally she
just got off a plane that had turbulence
she can't find her bag and now she wants
her man to be there her man calls her is
like the uber is outside it's a big
accident she don't want to hear any of
that [ __ ] she wasn't operating off of
logic at all logically she would have
been like if I love my man why would I
want him to be in trouble
an hour and a half does it make sense so
you see how the argument turned into a
huge argument like they argued for like
a month from that one time he's speaking
from it logically baby I love you I
ordered you a big-ass uber fan seat and
you'll be here in less than half an hour
she's like you don't love me I got off
of a plane and I had turbulence and
she's going through emotion you know
there you go bro it's like how do we
segue in the middle and if the girl I
told her if you keep throwing that
emotion [ __ ] at his way you're gonna
lose that guy he was very similar to you
he's a comedian
so like I was like be careful pushing
him because like like you both messed up
there but like if you're in an if you're
like whatever at Magic Castle and like
three weeks later you were still talking
about that and you're telling him you
don't love me because that I'm like
you're gonna lose him oh yeah it has to
be like and [ __ ] frustrated because
the plane imma [ __ ] crashed Lemmy Moe
babe let me be a [ __ ] [ __ ] let me be
just [ __ ] like like just mean and get
let the girl get it out of her system
tell her how you feel and then be like
I'm done baby just know that that [ __ ]
bothered me yeah don't bring it back up
she did so it's careful with like
pushing buttons with a guy that is kind
of closed off like you got a really kind
of like you know it slowly we literally
had something like this like a year ago
like I still remember this [ __ ] because
she was frustrated with how the house
was right it was a little messy was a
little dirty and by the way she's OCD so
her version of messy it's like nobody
would ever think it's messy like we've
had people come into our house and she's
like it's a mess and they're like what
are you talking about yeah that's how
clean she is so I was busy you know
doing work I was traveling and
everything else I was doing this Food
Show going in and out of the state
constantly and so when I came back I was
like hey how about this I will get a
maid service and they'll clean the house
up she responds she goes no I want you
to do it and in fear it made me so bad
because I was like it's okay this one
week I'll just get the maid to do it and
I'll pay it but she goes that's a waste
of money you need to do it because I've
been I always do it and I and I couldn't
wrap my head around what and I got so
mad because I was trying to help I was
like I can help but it wasn't in the way
that she wanted and it [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh man that should piss me off you know
you nailed it in that and that's the
biggest battle we have between you know
female and male its biggest one right
there
Holly and that's literally that uber
situation when you said I was like hold
the beste that's amazing oh my god Megan
do them 20 minutes they'll take me five
hours I'll be [ __ ] depressed and
[ __ ] angry I'm gonna argue at you
yeah I don't care I want you to do it
and I was like I'll stab my face right
now yeah that's it
holy [ __ ] that's so interesting holy
[ __ ] oh yeah right when you said that
I'm like okay it's a PTSD like but I
loved it you have a lot of
self-awareness man like a lot of guys
would justify it defend it and not
realize that there's an issue there like
you're very self-aware she took a lot of
time that I used to be that defensive
guy you know I think I might still get
defensive with people I [ __ ] hate but
you know it's just like regular
conversation with people you care about
I'm trying to learn how to just even if
I disagree with them right and I think
even on this podcast people like you
should use I want you to get somebody
who's like a hardcore Trump all lives
matter person it I would love to have
them here I just want to hear them hear
them speak and I think I'm why don't you
I'm trying to get somebody who's
level-headed that's why because you know
like for example one of the biggest
people that I've been trying to get on
here right now is an active cop an
active cop will not come on this podcast
whoa yeah and you know I think that
they're decent people the people that
I'm trying to talk to you but all of
them said the same thing they're like
well I want to be careful about what I
say because I'm still in the force I was
like and to me that makes me feel like
you're in a [ __ ] gang like you can't
say [ __ ] that how you feel because
you're afraid that you're gonna get
[ __ ] up that concerns me
you know and I was like I'm not here to
attack you I just want to know in this
situation in this country what is it
that went for what went wrong in your
opinion as a police officer right what
is something that we can do as a
civilian that will allow you to be
helped out or wonder stuff that you need
these are very simple questions I'm not
here to attack anybody they saying that
I don't need a cop in my life is [ __ ]
dumb I've been saved by cops multiple
[ __ ] times like multiple times they
came to save my ass so just say that I
don't need the police force is something
ridiculous but you know just I need
somebody to be open enough to have a
conversation and dialogue without
getting
I had a fan who hit me up said my
brother would I let me hit up my brother
and the first thing that she said was
like my brother just started going off
talking about how people don't [ __ ]
know this I'm like you are the worst
person they have on this podcast cuz
number one you're gonna make the police
force look terrible and then you're
gonna get me pissed off you know and
then if you piss me off I'm gonna mouth
off like a [ __ ] and it's recorded
so you beat my ass let's go No so that's
the conversation I don't want to have on
this podcast and you know I want things
to be open enough where I don't want
people to think that I'm just here just
to feed my ego I want I want to know I
want to have a conversation just do
where they come from yeah I think a big
component and we keep talking about in
this podcast is um lack of emotional
intelligence with cops like the power of
empathy right now should be like a
required 18-week course for cops new
cops that are getting into it empathize
jeez Louise
[ __ ] chills I'm on some crazy [ __ ] I
tells me to come on his podcast be like
pick up a girl girl but like I'll give
you a perfect example um
I barely ever get road rage because I
use a technique that I do who's the
number one person that I love more than
anything was planet my grandma she the
best driver no is she old yes do I love
her yes somebody cuts me off the first
thing that I go into is my emotional
intelligence because I teach that a lot
you could EQ it's like that's my grandma
that's my grandma she cut me off
I literally empathize with whoever's
there I'm like that's an old person
right or they don't know how to drive I
don't take it personal at all I put
myself in their shoes even if it's like
and like someone else I go they must be
having a bad day the power of empathy to
be like take off your shoes and put
somebody else's shoes on right now
you're a cop
there's a lot of good cops there's a lot
of bad cops if you can just take off
your shoes and be like wait a minute
what I do I teared up when I saw this
video I don't know if you saw it but it
was a little black kid shooting hoops in
his front in his front yard I know if
you saw it or did he hit away dude dude
it killed me be
because he heard the sirens and he's so
programmed to be like that dirt Durga
Nikhil's are the bad guys and he [ __ ]
hid behind the cop went then he started
to play ball yeah so like where do we
start like that that's gonna be his
experience you know what I mean like so
like for a white cop or whatever cop to
be like wait a minute like even if
they're being a little feisty right now
right even if they are protest like what
is it really to be in their position if
they can just pause and go oh man I'm
getting irritated just of people talking
about all this imagine being a black
person you're living with it yeah in its
corona [ __ ] virus I get pissed when
people look at me I have a mask on but
they look at me they're like yeah yeah
that's how they feel all the time yeah I
want to tell some what the [ __ ] you're
looking at me what the [ __ ] yeah so like
the power to empathize just to be like
dude calm down
more emotional intelligence more
teaching cops how to actually defuse
fights everybody's talking about it
jiu-jitsu yeah I did it for nine years I
love it it's like that wouldn't that
knee thing wouldn't have happened you
know it's like whatever that's the whole
new subs yeah but I literally just
tweeted this today
so [ __ ] bad yeah dude it's just I
mean you know just let's get some more
emotional intelligence into this and
then what I think a big component is by
the way I've had over a hundred cop
students that I've taught well a hundred
yeah a handful that came to me didn't
have childhood bullying experiences oh
really
all of them had similar traits they got
picked on and it couldn't get the girl
and now subconsciously if they're good
cops let's say cuz if just consciously
your [ __ ] dick dude yeah but
subconsciously they have this thing
within them that's like I'm gonna get my
power back
with this badge I'm gonna get this thing
okay now I get my power back it's
dangerous to go into that profession
when you're coming from that and you
haven't healed yeah because you're
walking into like situations where now
you have the power but you've spent 16
years all the way 18 years graduating
high school with having no power hmm and
now 48 hours later once you get the
badge now you have power we got to talk
about this man we got to open a forum
and be like what it what is your main
objective top 5 and being a cop and and
and and and I don't know I'm an
extremist do it I'll do a [ __ ] lie
detector because I bet power will come
up there a lot yeah as long as you're
self-aware dude you literally just said
you were self-aware you're like Cosmo I
have problems being into me because of
my child that's emotional intelligence
bro hmm you see when you defend it when
a cop's like nah I'm good I don't have
anger problems listen I don't it's like
dude like we got to talk about this man
yeah so I think it's an easy fix but I
think is such a hard topic to talk about
right now and usually the easiest thing
to do if it's too easy people be like
that's not the answer but it usually is
the answer but human beings we
complicate it so much the black guy that
did that YouTube clip where he was
talking to a white cop and then they
started unit getting chills again like
dude he's easy shaking things up he's
like he's like dude you know we got to
talk about it yeah and I'm so you know
like I think it's talking about it I
think it's like what we're doing right
now what why cops that are listening
right now like why not sit here and talk
and and and and and and see who isn't
about who's right or wrong see like how
we can get ahead yeah and it's that it's
it's that lack of understanding too is
why I get so angry and the reason why I
really want to bring somebody here is
for them to help bring down this anger
right because at this point we've all
heard our side what's yours
let's hear it because if there's a
reason for why you're like this not to
excuse whatever happened cuz [ __ ] that
but I need to understand why I need to
understand why it takes a cop takes four
or five cops
do one person that's not moving and you
think it's okay to put your knee on his
neck what made you think that was okay
what in your mind made you think that he
was such a threat that you had to keep
doing that there's a kid who died Elisha
McCain he was a kid he was I think he
was a little bit on the spectrum this
kid amazing kid right there's all these
clips of him
not a single evil bone in his [ __ ]
body the kid used to play violins for
like like foster cats like he's like one
of those he was going home he's had
trouble breathing because it was cold or
whatever but he had a ski mask on and
from that somebody called in and said
hey there's somebody walking around with
he had a grocery bag so he just went
shopping and they say there's a guy
walking around with a ski mask right a
scrawny little kid a little bit on the
spectrum dancing
you know having this time of his life as
he's walking home cops take him down
they said that he was on drugs or
whatever that he was grabbing for his
gun which the body cam showed that he
wasn't and they subdued him he threw up
on the spot
they gave him ketamine which caused
something else to happen his body and he
passed away and he died and I'm thinking
in that situation what caused that cop
to say he was grabbing for my gun he
didn't grab your gun why do you say that
why did it take four of you to do this
one kid and basically snuff out his life
and it didn't occur to you that you were
gonna kill this person there's something
to that
whether it's in your training whether
it's something that you're going through
emotionally because of your job or your
career there has to be something there I
I genuinely yeah I want to say in these
tweets and when I do that [ __ ] these
cops but at the same time there's a
everybody is the way that they are for a
[ __ ] reason and I want to know why
right because if I can understand why
then we can fix that problem and so
nobody's really having that conversation
I have theirs ex-con as an ex-cop I want
it I don't want you I want somebody
who's a current officer right now that's
in the thick of it because you were an
ex-cop for a [ __ ] reason here I mean
you chose not to be a for a reason I
want to know somebody now who enjoys a
career and what they're going through
right now you nailed it with the fact
that it really scares me that they do it
again segwaying back to the guys who
defend and justify what they do like it
scares me that he's not like [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up yeah
take me to [ __ ] jail I'm an idiot
[ __ ] but the fact that he has to
justify it and defend it brother
it scares me yeah that's the scary part
when I watched that belief like we've
you know been you know thinking the
Hobie lund thing and that was the first
time I saw a video where I looked at
this kid who's screaming he's like hey
it was hard to watch because he knew
that he was in danger and he started
saying things pleading for his life I'm
not like these other people
I'm not bla bla bla bla because he
already knew because of the color of his
skin he was at a disadvantage and so he
was like I'm not even like that
I don't even meet me eat meat I'm not
vegan he just started saying whatever he
could so not only did they take his life
away from they took his pride away and I
just wasn't it like today I started
bawling and I couldn't control it
because I was so angry I was sad just
watching that kid being having
everything stripped away from including
his life was so hard to watch the fact
that he has to beg for his life saying
I'm not like the other people that you
think that I am and the kid was just
walking home that's the thing where
somebody can do that and then you could
walk a home and feel okay like you
justified it and you feel not good about
it but saying like I had to do what I
had to do there's something wrong with
you there's a you shouldn't have a badge
right now or there should be some type
of therapy for you when you're a cop
there should be something provided that
gets you out of that mind state because
he thought it was okay you know I agree
it it's um [ __ ] up yeah it's so [ __ ]
up it's [ __ ] up and I'm like you did I
just want to be ignorant and get [ __ ]
angry as [ __ ] because it's like the
easiest thing because it's easy yeah and
the hard part is to sit back and go what
is a solution here like like how do we
do this and I think a lot of it has to
do with what's going on up here you know
a cop one of the cops that I taught when
he got into it the way that he got into
it I was like oh he's great cop and I'm
like brother why did you why did you
want to become a cop like we like what
made you
um and he told me he was like I um he's
like I felt like I I am he's like I felt
like I let down my last marriage um and
and and and previously my girlfriend and
my mom he started talking about all
these people that he felt like he
couldn't protect and he's like I want to
get into it because there's people with
no voices there's people that can't
protect themselves and I want to help
people and when he told me that I'm like
this is gonna be a good cop yeah cuz his
mindset Pro is that he's not done enough
to help people so he's getting this
badge going okay god don't kill me today
cuz I I know I'm behind I know I got a
help I know I got a help so his mind so
when he wakes up his help help help help
help
old lady watch you a little bit getting
him back of a cop car take you home help
help help
that's this objective when he wakes up
yeah an objective when you got your
power taken away when girls called you a
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] you get out of here
I don't want to go to prom with you and
you grow up and grow up you don't talk
to anyone about it you don't have a
shrink you don't have parents that are
listening you grow up you become a cop
you you're walking around with that I'm
going I wish a [ __ ] would [ __ ]
with me right now I know the [ __ ]
would watch i'ma show my other partners
I'm [ __ ] boss I wish I wish I
[ __ ] would and there's that
mindset of like getting my power back
through that you know I see that with
this one with this one cop his asian cop
he's been blown up all over the places
do name
Jarrod Ewan and you see him in the front
line with that same face I wish a
[ __ ] would bouncing back and
forth just happy to shoot anybody in any
second and I'm like you are such a small
man like you're waiting for that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] happened to you that
you're waiting they're waiting to she
give any [ __ ] reason that you want to
shoot somebody down what happened to
that guy and it's been bothering me it's
been bothering me a lot because people
asked me to do a video on him and I'm
like there's so much [ __ ] to say about
him I don't even know where to begin
because now I'm wondering why it's like
why you know I think we know why though
yeah I think it's this childhood to get
getting their power take getting his
are taken away bro it's like how I was
talking about earlier when you walk up
to the girl on your like who hurt you
literally that do the guys like walking
up to him going bro who hurt you yeah
was it your mom your dad your graphic
like who hurt you cuz these four black
kids or have nothing to do with 30 years
ago of what you went through yeah who
hurt you yeah but now homie alphas don't
talk about their emotions told me na now
you know what I mean now I'm gonna talk
about that you know like why yeah the
best fighters that I know are the most
patient people before they get into a
fight because they know that they have
so much responsibility on the line and
that people who can't fight that are
insecure about proving themselves punch
another guy in five seconds and then
start a fight same thing yeah best
fighters know that dude with this they
can go to jail for 20 years cops to you
have this gun that means you have to be
even more patient than regular people
yeah the other person doesn't have to be
patient you do same thing UFC fighters
do bro they get put debt they have
patience cuz they're like man this is
gonna be really bad for the other person
oh for sure oh for sure like how many
times are those guys in situations where
they're like you know what I could
literally kill you right now if I wanted
to and they don't do it because they
know about their power they know where
they stand man that's so yeah I was it
was funny that we're talking about this
because like I literally just talked to
my buddy right before you came here and
we're just talking about I wonder why
watching Elijah McCain's video why that
just broke me down the day you know and
even when I may be the guy not being
able to like very well with my fiance
it's like she came down she goes you
look so sad right now
I'm not crying you are yeah
you know I'm not cleaning okay what do
you argue about some spill this right
now
she's like you look so sad I was like
I'm sad I'm sad yeah who the [ __ ] sad
she just came out to me as she hugged me
and it felt really good that's all I
need that's it you know and I think that
was a very good move for her because I
didn't want to talk about it I just cuz
I couldn't even explain
in words why because I just experienced
I just watched that video and it tore me
so like for her I think it was nice that
she came and she just hugged me and then
she went back upstairs how they thank
you that's all I needed that's it yeah
what do you have right there oh yeah so
I was gonna show you this so this is
counterpunch this is um the first film I
ever wrote produce starting and it was
based on my life growing up in Miami and
yeah with Danny Trejo and Steven Bauer
from Scarface and uh you wrote this -
yeah I know they produced it I found him
money for it I had no idea and I shine
at being ignorant when it comes to like
being an actor we were talking about it
before what you like is the rejection
bro I'm as ignorant as they come
wouldn't be in an actor like I didn't
know how hard that was gonna be I'm
gonna raise the money they're like dude
you've never done a film like oh I'm
gonna do it so easily that I got it done
because I didn't know the odds of how
hard it was inside raise the money and
we sold it to Lionsgate that's amazing
ya got Danny Trejo on this man yeah yeah
[ __ ] crazy
yeah and I've gotten a lot of sweet
letters over the years from that movie
and you know it
um what did this come out like six seven
years ago oh [ __ ] yeah this is what was
it like doing your own film for the
first time was it was a cathartic but uh
scary a lot of digging deep and exposing
yourself yeah um fear that's so crazy
man like I I always when I see somebody
who gets to what people don't understand
about acting sometimes just like when
you when you play a character that
somebody else asks you to play it's very
difficult right but there's also this
other thing of there's a certain
satisfaction that you feel from creating
stuff that came from you like it feels
different it doesn't matter if some I
don't give a [ __ ] of a million people
hated it right it's as long as it was
true to me and I through it thoroughly
enjoyed it that's all that [ __ ]
matters right and I could only imagine
like what this felt like completing what
you were doing just because you had that
moment in your life for you like this is
what I'm made for and then you [ __ ]
made a film that's amazing and I forgave
my mom a lot through that film because I
had to write her character
so when you're writing you have to get
behind and justify each character yeah
so I had to write her dialogue and I'm
like oh I've never seen it through this
point of view oh that must do it off
open me up to being like wow okay yeah
yeah yes really young when she had me
she and I'm grateful she can get an
abortion she did that I started to open
up and be like I've never thought about
it like that and that's the power of
empathy but yeah but that kind of helped
out my relationship with my father a lot
because it was very very turbulent and
even till this day there's like remnants
of it because obviously it's not gonna
just disappear overnight but even for me
I got to empathize with my father
because he's so emotionally blocked off
I think I don't know anything about his
life story from his own mouth I had to
hear from my mom really at all like you
can say pops like what he'll just well
just dance around and he has very
general stories but my mom is the one
that kind of helped me understand who my
father is and who my father was right so
I had like he was so hard on me all the
time right and you know arguably there
was a point where I didn't talk to him
for almost two years because we got into
a huge huge fight and uh you know I
wanted to pursue what I wanted to pursue
but my father and my mom told me to I
think that the thing that kind of hit me
really hard she goes you know you you
fight with your father a lot I mean you
you feel like you know he has everything
and he just always pushes you down now
say but your father is probably one of
the saddest people I ever met in my life
and I was like why why do you say that
right now like he always he beats me
down you know so she goes your father is
somebody who is so emotionally
unintelligent that he wants to be your
best friend and he doesn't know how so
not only does he not have you as a
friend even though he wants you to be he
wants his family to be a certain way
he's so emotionally stupid he doesn't
know how he just keeps pushing you
further and further away so you have to
understand he's trying his best every
day but all he's doing is pushing you
further and further back and it tears at
him but he can't even tell you that but
he tells me I see it in him I've been
with him for it's you know since you
were born so that kind of helped me
understand my dad a little bit and I
kind of started to realize I'm expecting
my father to change into somebody he's
not going to be so I had to make a shift
in my life right it's like oh well my
dad says this this is what he means for
his me time my dad don't say this don't
say that he
he's not gonna do it he's already been
beaten and scarred his his like I found
out that my aunt my older on like kicked
him out when he was yo so it might my
grandpa used to be really wealthy back
in the day through a lot of financial
problems which I didn't even know about
my grandpa lost all of his money so my
so my dad became impoverished he was
super [ __ ] poor he so poor that my
his mom lived with my his older sister
so their mom live with an older sister
because her husband at the time took him
in but they said that my dad couldn't go
with him - I'll take you in you know
your mom and dad him but your brother
can't live with us so he has to figure
out a known way so his own sister kicked
him on the streets so he had to live
with his best friend and a motel that
they owned and that's that's where he
lived and that's where he had to survive
so he has this idea of what he wanted as
a close family because he never had it
even though he had his own siblings so
he didn't get to have that so it's like
but because he wasn't really talking how
to have a close family he doesn't know
how he was like you know your grandma
and your your grandfather you expect me
to have conversations with you and this
is the only time that he actually opened
up to me is this was like maybe three
years ago is where it's our last fight
that we ever had and I literally told
him like long story short with this when
he basically opened up and he said you
want me to have conversations with you
like you have conversations with your
mom I know I can't do that I was like
why why can't you do it I was like every
time you talk to me all you do is you
lecture me you call me dumb you call me
stupid whatever he goes I can't this is
how I talk because that's how your mom
that's how your grandfather and your
grandmother spoke to me this is all I
know like you want me to ask you how
your day is you want me to do I can't
that's your mom I can only talk to you
and love you the way I can so at this
point either you accept me for who I am
or you just or you're not going to love
me and I was like oh [ __ ] I'm wrong you
know I'm wrong I [ __ ] up because I
kept on expecting to be something that
he wasn't and that's what the thing I
was mad at him for I was doing the same
thing that he was doing to me but the
difference is is that I think my
responsibility as a younger generation
who had things that he didn't I should
be able to empathize it with him more
because he didn't have these tools I do
so I should be able to use it you know
it's kind of thank you for sharing that
man like yeah you're very self aware it
you know it's kind of like
everyone hearing us right now when do we
break the [ __ ] cycle yeah like when
does this [ __ ] stop like a like cuz you
either said it part of what the
arguments you get into with your girls
cuz you're kind of like your dad yeah as
I'm hearing you I'm like oh [ __ ] you're
him but you're but you're self-aware and
number two you take actionable steps to
be like okay I you know because look the
last 10 15 20 25 years self-improvement
has became the cool thing so now we're
all the Tony Robbins raw like aware like
okay we can improve ourselves all school
generations like your dad are like nope
is the way it's like literally he's
telling you I can't change and someone
like me is like bro you take my seminar
you could change that 30 hours so
literally homie you could change yeah
like you could so um I'm curious when's
the last time you guys said like you
said I love you to him or he said to you
yeah we don't say yeah I love you to my
mom yeah all the time I thought to my
mom probably three or four times a week
whenever I'm in the car and it's a drive
that's past 10 minutes I don't listen to
music actually just call her and we just
have great conversation my dad I don't
think he's ever said I love you to
people that you mention it I heard of
said I'm sorry once and I think it was
by accident like he he messed up a phone
number that he was supposed to give me
and as I is actually a stacy goes oh
sorry I was like what what I know he
knew the word but he said sorry that's
the only time I ever remembered him
saying sorry my mom even my mom doesn't
say sorry but she said I love you a lot
you know and that woman's crazy too yeah
I mean I love I love what you're saying
cuz like it's also the theory of nurture
versus nature like so we grow up and is
it like nature is the way that were
genetically hardwired like I'm gonna be
like this because my dad wasn't this XYZ
or can nature work where it's like you
get adopted parents but you get flooded
with validation compliments you're smart
enough Cosmo you could do it you could
do it but my twin that's genetically
just like me let's say that I have a
twin he he goes off to another like road
like gang member and killing people and
all that so I'm always fascinated with
like
I feel that Nate that that is even
though it were genetically hardwired
that way we can change it it's your mom
giving you love your mom give you that
empowerment you having someone in your
life where they can give you all that
love is really freaking important yeah
well man hey that was a deep podcast I
love it man we kind of opened up the
whole conversation to everything else
hey Cosmo where can they find you man
where can these guys get help I mean
just just talking to you right now
feeling that I had a lot of these
answers in my head I don't know [ __ ]
which is great so I mean somebody who
does I mean I don't I don't want to call
it like you know pickup artists advice I
would say more like life coaching and
kind of helping people with these social
situations where can they find you yeah
so my Instagram is coach Cosmo with a
case so coach Cosmo with a K and I'm
just launching a new platform called yes
man where I'm no longer like charging
money for like one product but it's like
an ongoing monthly thing where they can
have me in their life once a week I
check in on them give them challenges
give them things to do work on so it's
called yes-men and maybe can we touch a
link somewhere well yeah I'll put
whatever you have linked and so I mean
it's I I feel like what you know I'm
getting out on these platforms like
yourself and now people are seeing me
they're like damn I like this guy so I'm
doing like a like a whole new
reinvention it's called yes man and it's
all about like empowerment dating and
just like how do we keep it consistent I
used to do a lot of three days seminars
and then they would they're very
effective but what I found out is they
would be on a high for like four months
and then they would start to go back
into their old patterns so I'm like why
not do something like Netflix like every
month you pay for it and you have me in
your life and my coaches and things like
that so I'm gonna be I'm excited anybody
that has any kind of trouble with social
anxiety anybody that's going through
heartbreak anybody that suffering from
like just depression being lonely you
don't have anybody to go out with on the
weekends I have a step-by-step formula
and how you can reinvent yourself I did
it myself on national TV I'm the perfect
person cuz I've gone through all of it
to hell and back so yeah we'll attach a
link and my IG is coach Cosmo and
hopefully I can come back man
really alive dude this was a lot of fun
are those awesome well you guys can
catch the genius brain podcast every
Thursday in Sundays and you guys know
what it is
and we'll see y'all next time peace